All right. What's up, YouTube? As
always, welcome to another live stream.
We are going to be discussing one of my
favorite topics tonight, and that is one
of the cardinal doctrines of the
Christian faith, the Trinity.
The Adventist Church propagates the idea
that they are trinitarians.
But are they?
Tonight we're going to explore this. It
is important to understand that terms
have specific meanings. One of my
biggest pet peeves with the Adventist
church is their bamboozling of people by
term borrowing, then redefining it, but
then ardently asserting that they affirm
what others do because they simply use
the same term.
This muddies the waters. It confuses
people and it's dishonest.
They do this with terms like the
trinity, solos scriptura, righteousness
by faith.
Adventist leadership needs to own that
they are their own entity and religion.
Stop trying to play both sides of the
field publicly to appear like many of
them will assert that they're just
another Protestant denomination.
No, they're not. And they need to start
owning it and be forthright, not
deceptive. especially considering that
they claim to be the commandmentkeeping
church.
So tonight we're going to examine the
Adventist heavenly trio and we are going
to compare it with the Orthodox
Christian Trinity
and I want to answer this question as to
whether or not they are the same thing
or if we are talking about different
gods
and in the Adventist church's case gods
plural.
As always, we will leave the tail end
for Q&A, so have your questions ready,
but I will prompt you when to send those
through. Please don't do that now or
they're going to get lost in the chat.
With me to examine is a good friend of
mine, Pastor Jeremiah Nortiierre of the
125 Church in Arkansas. He's been on the
show before. Um, brother, welcome back
and thank you for being here.
It's always a pleasure. Thanks for
having me back on. Um, when you asked me
to talk about the Trinity, I was like,
"Hey, this is one of my favorite things
to talk about, too, because this is the
foundation of everything in
Christianity."
Yes, sir. Yes, sir. And it's actually
interesting. You just had Dr. Bosserman
on your channel to talk about this
specific topic. He's actually going to
be on this channel next month to talk
about the Sabbath.
So, that will be a really that will be a
really good stream. uh he actually has
some people in his family that are um
tertiary touching uh SDAs to some
degree. So should be a pretty
interesting topic. Uh it's going to be
in defense of first day sabotarianism.
So should be uh a good feather ruffler,
if you will. Um but with that said,
we're going to get right into it. Let's
do it.
So what we're going to do is we're going
to establish what the Trinity is
historically, biblically, all that good
stuff. Then we're going to examine a few
Adventist primary source documents. So,
it's not just going to be miles saying
this. It's just not answering
Adventism's bias. I've read these
papers. I've done deep digging on this
and I get a lot of SDAs that come
knocking my door down um upset that I
say some of the things I do. So, tonight
we're going to to see that I'm not
talking out the side of my neck here. So
with that said, can you explain to the
audience on a very surface level,
what is the doctrine of the trinity and
why is it so important? For for one,
it's so important because it is the one
true God that we worship. So that's
number one. And the name trinity,
triunity, that kind of begins to explain
the whole paradigm. God is tripal. He's
three persons, but he um is unified is
in in his eternal existence and nature.
His being is truly one. And so that's
what we mean. We we're trying to
understand these two important
categories. God is one in his being,
three in his personhood. And so I'm sure
we're going to get into uh a lot of
groups call foul and say, "Well, there's
not really a distinction between being
and person." We're saying you have to
have that distinction. In fact, we
understand this in our everyday um
experience. We see things that exist
that are impersonal.
You we contrast that with us. We are
human beings. We exist and we are
personal. But there's something
different between us and God. There's um
a different state of affairs altogether.
God is eternal in his existence. So his
personhood, how God is personal is
different than how we are personal.
Most definitely. Um, and we're going to
get into that a little bit further. Um,
but I think that's a good summation
there. But before we actually get into
the specifics of the doctrine, I think
it's important to establish this, and
that's what's on the screen.
The doctrine of the Trinity is not the
same thing as the biblical evidence for
the Trinity.
This is so important to grasp and
understand. This is why there's so much
confusion. This is why you will get
people that say things like, "Well, the
word trinity is not in the Bible." Even
though they're using the word Bible,
which isn't in the Bible. That is not
what the claim is. The concept of the
Trinity is found in the Bible. That's
the biblical evidence. The doctrine of
the Trinity is the language that we use
to describe what we find in the Bible so
that people can make sense with it
and make sense of what's being
presented. Because what we have in
scripture is, as we're going to to look
at, we have a plurality and a
singularity.
You have to have a way to understand the
differentiation between those two while
also still understanding the unity of
the two.
So the doctrine of the trinity is simply
the language that we use to describe
what the church sees in the Bible. So it
refers to the language and words that
the Christian church has used to
accurately describe what the Bible
teaches about the father, son, and holy
spirit. So being and persons, that's an
example. That's the language we're
using. We understand that scripture does
not say God is three persons in one
being and the hypothatic union and and
the you know, of course, we're we're
giving these things titles to what we
see. So we're not being verbose every
time we say it. And this is why I think
that properly defining things is so
important and not getting muddy on
things because it's the word itself is
shorthand for something specific. The
evidence for the trinity, the biblical
evidence is looking at the Bible in its
entirety
to see what it says regarding Christ and
his nature, the father, the holy spirit,
their characteristics and attributes. So
an example is Matthew 3:13-17. You see
all persons, all three persons present
at Christ's baptism. But it was not the
father that descended in the form of a
likeness of a dove onto the son. It was
the Holy Spirit that did that. It wasn't
the Holy Spirit that spoke from heaven.
It was the father that spoke from
heaven. The son was in the water, not
the holy spirit, not the father. But
then we have instances, as we're going
to look at, this is one of the examples
we will look at later, and I've brought
this out before on the channel. We have
Isaiah 44:24 in Colossians 1:16. where
you have a reference being made to one
of the persons, but then one of the
biblical authors applying that same one
Lord to Jesus.
So you have to be able to make sense of
what we're seeing in the Bible and we
have to have language to accurately
convey what we're communicating. And so
the doctrine of the trinity in the most
simple terms is that within the one
being that is God there exists eternally
three co-equal and co-eternal persons
namely the father the son and the holy
spirit
within the one being that is god there
exists eternally three co-eternal and
co-equal persons namely the father the
son and the holy spirit
there's one being that's what the church
has understood as monotheism
to be discussing.
As you're going to see tonight, we're
going to see a different idea of that
concept.
We then have that there three divine
persons and the persons are co-equal and
co-eternal.
So, how has the church defined and how
are they using the terms person and
being, Jeremiah?
Yeah. So, I'm so glad we're we're
highlighting these two categories
because um scripture is I loved how you
said when we got to look at the entirety
of the the scripture because as we see
the Old Testament unfolding, it's not
clear. There are glimpses glimpses of
God's plurality and his unity, right?
And so, but we see the Trinity in its
fullness with Jesus Christ coming. Um
and we see the apostles being
experiential trinitarians, right, with
the outpouring of the Holy Spirit at
Pentecost. And so when we look at the
entirety of the scripture, um we see
there is one God who exists. His being,
um is eternal. And that being is also
personal in a very unique way that's
distinct from our experience. It's very
similar. We're reflecting that triune
God's image um in many ways, but he is
eternally personal different than how we
are temporally personal. And so, for
example, you and I are two distinct
beings and two distinct persons, right?
And we're saying, okay, now God is
eternally one being. And that one being
is is fully shared with three divine
persons. And so
that's just important in saying we see
the being of God not being divided. That
is one that is where we get the strong
monotheism, right?
Yes.
And so does that kind of help um explain
the categories because when we start
looking at the term person um we see
that persons uh speak um they can
self-reflect. They can exhibit emotions.
And it's probably easy. Most people say
okay we kind of see that with the father
and the son. But the holy spirit is
given personal pronouns. He's uh
referred to as a he he will guide you
into all truth. The Holy Spirit uh
desires to give gifts and is spoken to
and he speaks to many people throughout
the book of Acts.
He also
he also intercedes and prays on our
behalf.
Yep. That's something a person does. And
another um
it's actually part of the evidence of
the Holy Spirit being and having the
divine attribution is that Paul tells us
that when the spirit prays and
intercedes on our behalf, he's able to
do so universally at all times for all
believers in all places, which is a
divine attribution.
Absolutely. And Acts 5, I think, is
another wonderful passage to show the
deity of the Holy Spirit because Ananas
and Safara lied not to man but to God
and to the Holy Spirit. we see in that
context, but that's also a proof of the
personhood of the Holy Spirit because
you don't lie to rocks. That doesn't
make any sense. But you lie to other
persons. And so the Holy Spirit was lied
to.
Correct.
And you brought up the Jesus's baptism.
And so we see a strong distinction
between the father that spoke from
heaven, this is my son who I'm well
pleased, with the the dove, the spirit
um descending like a dove onto Jesus.
That was the spirit right onto Jesus at
his baptism. So these are three persons
that are distinct from one another. The
the father did not die on the cross. I
know that's an ancient heresy, but it
was the son um who's been in eternal
relationship with the father and he is
the one that condescended, took on flesh
and is our savior ultimately.
So this is where the battle is had in
terms of explaining with greater clarity
about the trinity is making these two
distinct categories. And when I teach on
the trinity, I say without these two
distinct categories, it's nonsense.
Jehovah's Witnesses will say, "Explain
the trinity because it sounds like you
you serve one God sometimes and then you
serve three gods sometimes." And that is
you're understand the trinity. That is
absurd to say, "Well, we believe in one
God sometimes and sometimes it's three."
Well, that's nonsense, right? We're
we're created in God's image to reflect
truth and so we want to be logically
consistent.
Yes. So here is a succinct
definition of what we mean when we use
these terms.
Person is the conscious ability meaning
possessing awareness
to will, speak, self-reflect and exhibit
emotions. These are the sorts of things
that we see from father, son, and holy
spirit in holy scripture.
That is not relegated to only physical
creatures.
People oftentimes associate personhood
with being a human being.
And there are some contexts where that
can be the case, but that's not what the
church means when the church is using
that term that it's three human beings.
We're going to circle back around to
this actually um on the latter half of
of this stream, but that's not what
we're saying. We're saying the ability
to will, self-reflect, exhibit emotions,
speak, be spoken to, etc. And that's not
relegated to only physical creatures.
Spiritual creatures can also experience
those things like angels.
Yep.
They also have the ability to do these
things.
So it's not necessarily a physical
corporeal form
that has this possession. So when we
talk about the persons, we're talking
about the who of God. Who are who is
God? Father, Son, Holy Spirit. That's
who God is. That's where you have your
plurality.
The being is the mode or state of
something or someone's existence.
This headphone case has being but no
personhood.
So something can have being and not have
personhood. It's simply something's
state or mode of existence. This is the
what of God.
What is he? And that's when we get into
the divine attribution being ascribed.
things like omnipresent, omniscient,
omnipotent, those are descriptions of
the divine.
And those things are ascribed to Jesus,
the Holy Spirit, and the father in
scripture, as we're going to to look at
tonight. So, you have to have a way of
saying, well, these three persons
uh are able to interact with not just
creation, but one another.
So they're not one another in the fact
that they speak to one another sometimes
the like we talked about with Jesus's
baptism.
But at the same time you have the divine
attribution the being the the like you
said the eternal state of being is
shared by all three of those persons and
there's only one of those.
So that's important to understand the
three who's the singular what.
So Christian trinitarianism could be
displayed in this left chart. This is
the infamous trinity shield.
The one being is the central the one
lord Yahweh.
That is the being that is shared then by
three persons who are not one another.
Now remember how we're using these terms
person and being can emote,
self-reflect, speak and will. The being
the mode of existence. So what makes
them one? The attributes, the being, the
essence, the substance. These are
various terms that the church has used
to describe this down through the
centuries
compared to the Adventist heavenly trio.
Whoa.
We're going to get into this in the
second half, but I I wanted to bring
this up now while we were doing this
comparison here to show you the
distinction and and difference. The
Adventist Church defines person and
being as essentially the same thing as
we're going to see. But for the purpose
of this comparison here, I'm still using
it as being to see why we would say or
to to show why we would say this is why
you should not say being and person are
interchangeable.
So I've put it on here as mode of
existence because that's what being is
ontology.
But they say a person is defined as
possessing a distinct tangible physical
form
and can also emote self-reflect and will
etc.
Again, they're going to use being and
person interchangeably.
But the way that we would what
Christians hear when they hear them say
three beings, you've got three modes of
existence.
And this is the way Ellen White
described the heavenly trio by the way
is that each member is for example uh
self-existent
and autonomous etern like eternally.
So in orthodox trinitarianism like we
have in the the previous chart uh you
can't the the sun is not a standalone
being and god.
That's why people they get accused of
tritheism as again we're going to look
at tonight. Um because if you remove one
of the persons from this, you don't have
God anymore. It's not three standalone,
that'd be three gods.
So again, that's why these terms are
super important to define specificity
around what we're saying. But this chart
is a better example. And here you can
see a sidebyside of the the difference.
What makes the Adventist Heavenly Trio
supposedly one is their mission and
their purpose. Now, I wouldn't disagree
with that. The Christian church would
not disagree with that. Of course, they
are united in mission, purpose, etc. But
that's not what makes them one God.
That's the key. You are not one God
because you have three individual
persons, which they're incorrectly
defining or defining it differently,
who are united in their mission. So,
therefore, it's one God. No, that's not
how it works.
So, what isn't the doctrine of the
train? Now that we've established what
it is, again, if you need to go back,
folks, and and watch those parts again,
I encourage you to do so. Um, there's
something very specific being said here.
And this is it in the most basic terms.
And it's not to say that we understand
all the mechanics around this, but we're
talking about something here that is the
foundational core crux of the Christian
faith.
I will stand, Jeremiah will stand and
Christians will stand with Athanasius
the Great saying I don't care if the
world is against Athanasius then it's
Athanasius against the world. This is
the central defining doctrine of the
Christian faith. So with that said, what
isn't the Trinity?
Well, the the Trinity is not we worship
three gods, right? That's maybe the
first thing we should point out because
that's to me the basic folly of the the
heavenly trio because when you divide
the being and start dividing the essence
of God, you have multiple gods and you
have now polytheism, not monotheism.
And uh there's a video on YouTube uh bad
analogies by St. Patrick. Uh it's a
classic. I want people to go look that
up because he talks about Patrick
that's modalism Patrick. And I love it
because it's it's modeling all the
analogies we want to use to try to
explain God. And so u the the trinity is
is not like water where where God is
sometime you got a mode where or water
takes on vapor or takes on a liquid or
take on a solid. Well that that's
modalism. That is God being one person
just operating in three different modes
or putting on three different masks. um
it erodess the the the distinction
between the three persons of God. Um you
know I I love St. Patrick's uh threeleaf
clover analogy because you know
historically he actually used that to to
try to rightly explain the trendy and
I've told people I'm a little bit soft
when you use an analogy and then talk
about where it breaks down. So as long
as you have that caveat you can help get
the ball rolling a little bit. But the
problem with like a threeleaf clover is
kind of dividing God into thirds,
saying, "Well, the father is a third of
God, the son is a third, and the holy
spirit is third." It's like, "No,
they're all fully co-equally eternally
the one true God."
And so all human analogies, created
analogies break down in a heretical way
because you can't capture something from
the created order on the eternal state
of affairs which is God who is uh not
changing. He is aay um he is totally
self-existing. God is his attributes.
That's why God told Moses in the burning
bush, I am that I am. Um he is
unccreated. He is self sustaining.
And so um one last thing, one one last
model of what the trinity is not and
it's another form of modalism. Uh the
trinity is not like a man who is a
father. He can also be a son and a
brother. What's the fallacy there?
That's one person operating um or at
least having these different functions.
And so we're saying no, the father is
distinct as a person, a divine person
and uh from the son and the holy spirit.
And so they've all eternally been in a
harmonious, perfect, loving
relationship.
Yeah. From eternity past.
From eternity past before the foundation
of the world.
Yeah. So the trinity is not you just
described it there at the end modalism
or the the ancient term selianism.
There you go.
It's not that that god is one singular
person unipersonal
and at different times that singular
person manifests himself at different in
different modes. Uh so sometimes he's
the son then sometimes he's the father
then sometimes he's the holy spirit.
It's also not Aryanism
obviously again ancient heresy that
Jesus is a created being
of lesser status than
the father or the holy spirit. It's also
not tritheism
three gods which is kind of what this
heavenly trio more closely resembles.
Is the trinity a pagan concept?
Absolutely not. Um,
have you heard people say this?
Yeah. Yeah, I've heard people say this.
I'm like, how can it be? It is distinct
from all pagan thought.
The Trinity claims to be monotheistic
and tripal. Show me anything in paganism
that comes close to that. You can't um
you're going to get an extreme of a of a
unity, a a a unitarian god, like you
said earlier, or you're going to get
like Mormonism, a pantheon of gods. And
so we're saying for one, those gods
cannot account for the uh the diversity
and the unity of the world that we live
in. Um because those types of uh faulty
gods are going to fall prey to the
problem of the one and the many.
Totally. Well, and as we're about to see
right now, I want to transition into
some of the biblical evidences now that
we've talked about the doctrine
specifically. Um I'm I'm going to go
through quite a few here. I want to hear
some that you have first. um if you have
anything to share. Um but I have a lot
of verses to look at here to really
drive this point home
um before we then transition into our um
other examination. So what sort of
biblical evidences would you give to
somebody who asks for
biblical evidence for the trinity?
Great great question. U in fact I've
recently taught on the trinity at the
apologetic dog. Definitely want to
encourage people to go check that out.
And the interview with BA Bosterman, I'm
so glad he's coming on your channel. We
talked about why God is necessarily one
and three, not one in two, one of one in
four or one in a 100.
But I think what's foundational, and
this actually hits me on a personal
level because uh many years ago I was
sharing my faith to Jehovah's Witness,
they asked me, "Where's the trinity?"
Miles, I was unequipped, man. I couldn't
find the verse that has the word trinity
in it. couldn't appeal to the the whole
testimony of scripture to show that God
is one and three. One being three
persons. So now it's a different story.
I want to say look at the consistent
testimony how God is one. The great
shama in Deuteronomy 6 um every faithful
Jew would be quoting the shama when they
get up throughout the day and before
they go to bed here. O Israel, the Lord
our God is one. Okay, this is a
fundamental truth that you see all
throughout the Psalms, all throughout
the prophets. Isaiah talks about there
is one God and there's no other besides
me, the one creator, God who is Yahweh.
And so in the gospels, Jesus quotes the
great Shama, affirming monotheism.
And we see the epistles in the in James
and uh 1 Corinthians 8:6 quoting the
shama. There's one true God who is the
creator. We are the creation. He's the
creator. So that's the testimony of all
of scripture. The one being who is God.
Now Yahweh, we start to see, okay,
Yahweh has revealed himself in the
father, in the son, and the spirit. That
is to say, there is biblical support.
John chapter 1, in the beginning was the
word, the word was with God, and the
word was God. Well, that's trinitarian
language. This eternal word is not an
abstract thought or that's being spoken
with um a a word. It's a divine person.
How do we know that? Well, verse 14
tells us that word took on flesh. We
know later uh this is the son, Jesus.
Grace upon grace. And verse 18 says that
the father and the son, the unique son
of God, the monogan theos eternally has
been in face-toface relationship.
And so there's so many things we could
point to say, well obviously the
father's god. Uh scriptures tell us
that. I think it's John uh 6 maybe 29 in
there um tell us clearly God the father.
So we see that that the the one being
who is God is the father. We see that
one being that um is God is the son.
Clear testimony Jesus forgave sin.
That's something God alone can do. Um
and then we see wonderful passages about
uh God the spirit, the holy spirit um u
you know is Yahweh speaking um in many
different passages. So we see a lot of
these u scriptures and then when I tell
people okay you want a verse you want a
verse Jehov Mr. Jehovah's Witness. Let
me give you one. Uh when we go to the
great commission, and by the way, Miles,
did you know the great commission is not
fulfilled? I've had people try to argue
opposite of that. When you go to the
great commission, um Jesus says, "Go
therefore make disciples of all nations,
baptizing them in the name, singular,
the name of the father, of the son, and
of the holy spirit." And so I've had,
you know, witness Pentecostals say,
"Well, go read Acts 2:38." I'm like, I
debate so many Church of Christ. Trust
me, I understand what uh Peter is saying
over there at Pentecost, but they say
the name being referred to is the name
of Jesus Christ. I'm like, time out.
Nope, that's not it. Number one, Jesus
was a Jew. I know that's groundbreaking
news for some people, but he would have
been a faithful Jew. The best one, by
the way, quoting the Shama here, O
Israel, the Lord our God is one. In
which he quotes the first and greatest
commandment. So, we know he's faithful
to the schmal, affirming monotheism. And
so, that is the name that Jesus is
talking about here, Yahweh. Right? Now,
it's interesting because he doesn't say
baptizing them in the names plural,
father, son, and spirit. No, he's saying
in the in the name of the one true God
who is father, son, and spirit. And so
simply in Acts two, that's just talking
about be baptized in the the authority,
in the name and the power of Jesus
Christ, the way that he prescribed us to
be baptized if people have questions
about that. So that's one of my favorite
verses. There's tons of trinitarian
verses um that we can go to, but this to
me is is one of the clearest where you
have the name singular and then you see
that name, which would be Yahweh,
Father, Son, and Spirit.
Amen. Um, you covered a couple of the
ones that I want to look at here, but
you also No, you're good. You also
listed a bunch that I'm not going to.
And so, just to piggyback off of that,
um, I want to walk through a good
portion of verses. So, you mentioned the
schma,
you know, real quick,
I could quote it in Hebrew, but I
listened to a rabbitic Jew, so he said
Adonai instead of Yahweh, so it kind of
messed me up.
Oh, yeah. So, explain though. How would
is how would Israel and including Christ
um have understood what is being said
with one
right? You got to have the
yes
the little thing back there.
Yeah.
God is one
and this is a consistent testimony like
I said throughout the Psalms throughout
Isaiah. There is only one God and there
is no other. Um Isaiah 42, you may pull
that up later, but this one God shares
his glory with no other.
And people that deny the Trinity. Good
luck trying to harmonize that with John
17, by the way. Um, but yeah, a a Jew
here would be bowing the knee to the
creator, the one that spoke this
universe into existence. I believe
that's Psalm 33. By the word of his
power, he sustains all of his creation.
So, this faithful Jew would be
worshiping the one, the radical one God
who exists, the creator of all things.
Yes. So we see here as well that there
is one Lord as well.
Yes,
there aren't multiple lords.
You'll see people like Dale Tuggy and
the the Unitarians of today oftentimes
want to appeal to well when we see the
term Lord in the New Testament. It's not
the same sense that it's used in the Old
Testament because they have to make two
Lords.
You can't have Jesus being the Lord in
the New Testament. But then here the
understanding being well no it's in
reference here to what they would have
understood to be God the father.
The unarians can't go ahead
spice in there. Um did you happen to
have Psalm 110 in your many verses?
No but that's on I mean I have a log of
of all the support for this and it's in
that log. That's just not one I picked
for tonight. Do you want to go there?
Yeah, I I'll do just a quick uh drive
through on this because this is
incredible because I believe it's in
Matthew 22. You may have to correct me
if I'm wrong, but Jesus expounds on this
um in the Gospels, but this is
incredible. Says, "A Psalm of David, the
Lord says to my Lord who sits at my
right hand until I make an enemy of your
foottool." There's your hashtag postmeal
verse, too, by the way. I'm sure you
like that. But um a lot of our
translations do us a favor of
capitalizing Yahweh, right? All caps
Lord. And then we see Lord Adoni uh
being distinguished here with the second
Lord. And so Jesus kind of poses the
question um if if Adonai is supposed to
be a descendant of David, how is he in
the present um praying to him ultimately
in relation to Yahweh? Well, this is
because Adoni um pre-exist David, right?
And so this is Jesus. Jesus has
eternally existed, the divine uh eternal
logos. He just stepped into time, took
on flesh through the virgin birth,
right? But if you abandon a trinitarian
understanding, then this makes no sense.
How can David pray in the present during
his time to Adoni who is supposed to be
the coming savior, right?
Yeah, that's a good point.
I love asking Jews about that and they
do not have in my opinion very good
sophisticated um rebuttals to Psalm 110.
You may have the verse later in maybe
Genesis 18 or 19 where you have Yahweh
um being talked about in one location,
then Yahweh in another location. It's
like wait, we know there's one Yahweh
and yet we understand there's two divine
persons at at work.
It's actually interesting. I'm going to
be getting into not this specific thing
regarding the tarum um or the taramme
but uh the tarams also throw them off
oftentimes if uh we're talking about the
plurality. I think it's um Anthony
Rogers was doing a video the other night
talking about this. Um I think it's
taram neaphiti uh on Genesis and the
plurality of Genesis 1 regarding the
godhead and um yeah that's just an
interesting observation on your part. Uh
but again
What's that
you say? Rafiki.
Uh, no. I don't know what that is.
Off the Lion King. Rafiki.
Oh, you got to put your behind in the
past.
Yeah. For some reason, I thought you
were referring to an individual like
some rabbi or something like that.
No, no, you're good. Um, but then again,
we see the same thing here again. One
Lord. Paul tells us Ephesians 4, there's
one body, one spirit, just as you were
called to the one hope that belongs to
your call. One Lord, one faith, one
baptism, one God and Father of all, who
is over all and through all and in all.
So this is another interesting one here
because you have a
and you have a plurality being spoken of
here regarding one spirit, one Lord, one
God, and father of all. Um, but the
point with me quoting this here, there's
a lot you could get into with this, but
the point being is that there's one
Lord.
Deuteronomy 6:4, uh, other pl there's
multiple places that say this in
scripture. There is only one Lord. Well,
with that being established,
let's go to
Miles. When I hear that passage, I just
hear the church of Christ saying, "One
baptism, Jeremiah." I'm like,
"Yeah,
it's like you think I deny that, but
this is rooted in a trinitarian uh
passage where there's of course there's
one faith. There is one baptism. There's
there's one God,
right?
So if we look at Revelation
uh oh in vain of this one Lord this
theme because that one Lord as you've
mentioned is Yahweh.
Revelation
18 is about Jesus.
I am the Alpha and the Omega says the
Lord God. Again there's one Lord who is
and who was and who is to come. the
Almighty.
That's Yahweh. How do we know that this
is about Jesus? Well, because Revelation
11:17-18 and 28 prove this is about
Jesus. Because those verses are him
speaking. And what does he say?
When I saw him, this is John. I fell at
his feet as though dead, but he laid his
right hand on me, saying, "Fear not. I
am the first and the last." That's alpha
and omega. And the living one, I died,
and behold, I am alive forever more. I
have the keys of death and Hades.
So what did 18? I am the alpha and the
omega. That's the first and the last
says the Lord God who is and who was and
who is to come, the Almighty. Again 28
Jesus speaking. And to the angel of the
church in Smyrna, write the words of the
first and the last who died and who came
to life.
That's alpha and omega.
Revelation 19:16
talking about Jesus again on his robe
and on his thigh. He has a name written
King of Kings and Lord of Lords.
Miles, is that a tattoo on Jesus?
Yeah,
interesting discussion.
King of Kings and Lord of Lords. Again,
one Lord.
Revelation 15:3.
And they sang the song of Moses, the
servant of God, and the song of the
Lamb, saying,"Great and amazing are the
deeds are your deeds, oh Lord God, the
Almighty. Just and true are your ways, O
king of the nations."
Jesus is the king of the nations.
But Revelation also uses alpha and omega
of the father as well. The father
speaking, Revelation 21:6.
And he said to me, "It is done. And I'm
the alpha and the omega, the beginning
and the end. To the thirsty I'll give
from the spring of water of life without
payment.
If you have your red letter Bible,
that's not going to be in red.
Oh, it's the father speaking. The father
again, actually the son here.
Behold, I'm coming soon bringing my
recompense with me to repay each one for
what he has done. I am the alpha and the
omega, the first and the last, the
beginning and the end.
So you have the Almighty, the one Lord,
Yahweh, the Father claiming that, the
Son claiming that.
Furthermore, and we've looked at this
one on the channel before, folks, so
it's always good to just rehash these
things out. If you've seen this before,
bear with me. In Isaiah 44,
Yahweh is
speaking
and talking about his uniqueness amongst
all the other idols.
Specifically in verse 24, well, yeah, he
talks about the penalty for falling into
idolatry, etc. leading up to this. But
then he says, "Thus says the Lord, your
redeemer, who formed you from the womb.
I am the Lord, the one Lord, who made
all things, who alone stretched out the
heavens, who spread out the earth by
myself. So Jeremiah, who made all
things?
The Lord.
The Lord alone.
The Lord alone made all things.
Correct.
But Paul tells us in John 1 1-3, which
you read some of earlier,
in the beginning was the word. The word
was with God. The word was God. He was
in the beginning with God. All things
were made through him. And without him
was not anything made that was made.
You'll get your Jehovah's Witnesses here
that will tell you, well, yeah, yeah,
through him, not by him. Okay.
Colossians 1:16. For by him all things
were created in heaven and on earth,
visible and invisible, whether thrones
or dominions or rulers or authorities.
All things were created through him and
for him. C
can I can we go back up to John one also
because verse I'm so glad you included
verse three. The way that John says this
is very interesting. All things were
made through him and without him was not
anything made that was made. And so
you're trying to posit that Jesus was
somehow made.
You lit you have a self-contradiction
because he would have had to exist in
order to be made through himself like to
be self-created which is absolutely
absurd. Yeah. uh John 1, Colossians 1,
Hebrews 1 talks about Jesus is Yahweh
create because as like we're getting
into um the the creator is a triune act,
right?
Yes.
Back to Isaiah 44
like we were earlier.
Earlier in the passage again, Yahweh is
laying out his uniqueness. Says, "Fear
not, nor be afraid. Have I not told you
from of old and declared it? And you are
my witnesses. Is there a God besides me?
There is no rock. I know not any. The
same thing is reiterated again in
Deuteronomy 32. The rock, his work is
perfect, for all his ways are justice. A
God of faithfulness and without
iniquity, just and upright is he. 2
Samuel 22, same thing. The Lord lives
and blessed be my rock and exalted be my
God, the rock of my salvation. Psalm 95.
Oh come, let us sing to the Lord, the
one Lord. Let us make a joyful noise to
the rock of our salvation.
But then in 1 Corinthians 10, what does
he say? Jeremiah,
I do not want you to be unaware,
brothers, that our fathers were all
under the cloud, talking about Israel
with Moses, and all passed through the
sea, and all were baptized. That
includes infants, by the way, brother
into into Moses in the cloud and in the
sea. And all ate the same spiritual
food. That includes the children, too,
by the way. And all drank the same
spiritual drink. For they drank from the
spiritual rock that followed them, and
the rock was Christ.
I have to be nice to you since I'm on
your channel.
You can get me back when we uh do
another stream over over on your
channel. We kid, folks. It's all in fun.
Um that just shows that we can have
unity while being uh in different
denominations despite what the Adventist
church tries to tell people.
Um so yeah, as you see, Yahweh is the
rock. The rock is then applied to Jesus.
You mentioned this in passing a little
bit earlier. Only God can forgive sins.
Let's see what First Kings 8:39 says.
This is Solomon's prayer of him when he
was dedicating the temple.
Whatever prayer, whatever plea is made
by any man or by all your people Israel,
each knowing the affliction of his own
heart and stretching out his hand
towards the towards this house, then
here in heaven your dwelling place, and
forgive and act and render to each whose
heart you know according to all his
ways. For you, you only know the hearts
of all the children of mankind, that you
may uh that they may fear you all the
days that they live in the land that you
gave to our fathers.
Psalm 44:21.
Who would not God disco or would not God
discover this? For he knows the secrets
of the heart. God knows the secrets of
the heart. God alone forgives sins and
knows the thoughts of the heart of men.
First Kings 8:39 told us, "Then again
Psalm 103 2-3,
blessed the Lord, oh my soul, and forget
not all his benefits. who forgives all
your iniquity. That's sin. Who heals all
your diseases.
So Yahweh forgives sins, heals diseases,
knows the secrets of the heart, knows
the thoughts of men. Did you catch all
those? Now let's look at Mark 2 5-10.
What does it say? And when Jesus saw
their faith, he said to the paralytic,
"Son, your sins are forgiven."
Now, some of the scribes were sitting
there questioning in their hearts, why
does this man speak like that? He's
blaspheming.
They knew the Old Testament scriptures.
You think they'd read First Kings,
brother?
Absolutely.
Why does this man speak like that? He's
blaspheing. Who can forgive sins but God
alone? And immediately Jesus perceiving
in his spirit
that they thus questioned within
themselves said to them, "Why do you
question these things in your hearts?"
Did you catch that?
Jesus knew the hearts of these men. What
did we just read in the Old Testament?
That God alone knows the hearts of men.
Ah, when it uses the phrase, just as a
fun fact for folks, when you hear the
phrase uh in his spirit, that's
referring to the divine nature of of
Christ.
When you hear the phrase according to
the flesh, that's his human nature, like
in Romans 1:3 and uh 9:5.
According to the flesh is referring to
his humanity. This gets into the
hypothic union, the attribution um being
ascribed to the singular person of
Christ. We're not going to get into that
tonight. U we'll get into that some
other time. But um
why do you question these things in your
hearts? Which is easier, to say to the
paralytic, "Your sins are forgiven." Or
to say, "Rise, take up your bed, and
walk?" But that you may know that the
son of man has authority on earth to
forgive sins, he said to the paralytic.
So Jesus does all three things there
that Yahweh alone
can do. There are many, many, many
others of these that we could look at,
but the point being
the father's not the son, the son is not
the father, spirit's not the father,
spirit's not the son, etc. Back to our
little shield.
Can I add one more in there?
Yep.
And this is this is pretty intuitive.
People would understand that God alone
is to be worshiped, right? And so this
doesn't apply to the Adventist, but a
lot of people that deny Jesus as being
the one true God, um he received
worship. Um and scripture is clear like
when when John in the throne room of
heaven in the vision tried to worship an
angel, the the angel says, "Get up. I'm
not God. Don't worship me." And he
points him back to Yahweh. And one of
the best examples of Jesus receiving
worship. Because you know Jesus, if he
wasn't a created being but being like
the most faithful Jew, he would have
deterred worship away from him, right?
Remember Thomas, my Lord and my God,
when he felt his hands and felt his side
um affirmed who Jesus was as being Lord
and God and Jesus blessed him. Blessed
are you, Thomas, but you've you've seen
these things, right? But blessed are
those who haven't seen these things and
yet believe these things in their heart.
Amen.
So, with all that said,
now I want to transition into what the
heavenly trio is.
Oh, snap.
So, let's compare now moving forward and
see if
this is trinitarianism because again,
they want people to think, "No, no, no,
we're trinitarian." At least the main
what you're going to find tonight,
brother, which this I'm sure will send
up red flags for you. Um,
there's multiple camps in this movement
that are accepted. You don't have to be
a trinitarian.
That's not that's not a that's not a
dividing line. Eating bacon is
premillennial historicist is, but you
can be an Aryan heretic. You can be a
tritheist. You can be uh
you can have all sorts of
why this is so important. Um, you may
look this up if I'm wrong, but I think
it's it's John 8:24
where Jesus says, "Unless you believe
that ego I me, then you will die in your
sins." Here's the point. You have to
believe in the right Jesus. I think it's
2 Corinthians 11 through4.
Yeah. Uh where Paul warns us to beware
of false Jesus's. So, we need God's word
to tell us clearly who he is. And so
we're contending there's only one true
and living God who is trippersonal. So
when people say, "Oh, I believe in
Jesus." Well, who are you calling Jesus?
Because we know biblically that it's the
second person of the triune God. And so
if you deny that, you are getting into
John 1 or John 8:24 territory denying
Jesus as the eternal I am. And so to
deny that Jesus,
you you're in your sense. And so it's
it's equal to the Galatians one heresy
to where you will be a NAS.
Yeah. There is no um other Jesus like
simply saying the name is not enough,
right? The details matter because every
heretic down through history has always
used the name. Sellius used the name.
Aras used the name. All sorts of groups
have used the name Jesus. But when you
start to get into, well, who are you
talking about? Who is that Jesus? That's
where the rubber starts to meet the
road. So here, let's look. This is on
the Adventist church's website. They had
somebody reach out to me uh back in
December who told me that this was just
a slip of the keystroke. He assured me.
He wanted me to know that. No, no, no.
He's one of these. No, we we believe the
Trinity. You're getting caught up on
semantics, man.
Yeah. Okay. It'll be ch it'll be changed
within 72 hours, he said. That was in
December, folks, of last year. It's
almost June. Hasn't changed.
Oh,
that's because And that's because they
know. Yeah. And that's because they know
it. So, we're going to put this on blast
and put this out on a megaphone
because I don't think that this is is
something light.
You need to be honest about what you
believe. This is serious. Stop trying to
blend in with the rest of Christian,
especially when you guys think that
Protestants are apostate. That we need
to leave our churches and join your
guys's church. You have your own thing
going on. Own it. Own it. Seventh Day
Adventist Christians believe that there
is one God. We're going to get into how
they how they define the word God,
Jeremiah. Okay?
and that this one God is three
co-eternal beings who work together in
unity.
Do you see the problem? You said you saw
it earlier. I I knew you would
be I mean if anything I glance and it's
like for me that was in all caps and
yellow and big and I'm like whoa stop
because that's polytheism right that's
where
yeah
front and center the first sentence on
the page about what they believe about
the trinity
I asked this guy who who contacted me
why did it take a YouTube armchair
theologian to bring this to your
attention
none of your scholars
none of your professors caught this if
this is what you guys He said, "Oh, no.
We're going to change it to say just
three persons." I said, "Okay, well,
what about the being?" He said, "Well,
we don't really comment on that because
the Bible doesn't use that word." I
said, "Where's the Bible used that God
is three persons."
No, what it really comes down to with
the next in one of the sources that
we're going to look at after this
is that Ellen White defines for them
what the Godhead is. and she uses the
terms person and being interchangeably,
which is why they're not going to have
three persons, one being, and make a
distinction between the two because they
don't believe a distinction between the
two as we're going to see. Well, then if
you keep scrolling through, you can read
about a number of things. And even
within this article, they use the term
three persons later on. So, they say
three beings and three persons. So,
either they're using it interchangeably
or you have three persons, three beings,
which is still not trinitarianism.
But at the end, brother, I want to read
this last part to you
because this is a key aspect. How does
the trinity work together?
And I'm going to read this whole section
to you and then I want to get your
thoughts at the end. Okay?
Have you ever been on a winning team?
This is already going in bad
temperature.
We were just talking about bad analogies
earlier.
Yep.
A a team of students at school raising
money. A team of co-workers trying to
meet a sales goal. A community sports
team. It's fun to be on the winning the
winning side. A team has a common goal.
While each person
may fill a different role, they all work
together to accomplish the mission.
So here's the analogy. It's not the egg
analogy. It's not the apple where it's
like, oh, you have the skin, the meat,
the core. That's what the trinity is.
This is the the analogy we're getting. A
team.
The triune God
may be compared to a winning team.
God the Father, God the Son, and God the
Holy Spirit work together in what? In
ways that a human team would never be
able to for a common goal. While each
person of the Godhead has a distinct
role in the plan of salvation, they
unite in their mission.
Paul writes to the church at Corenth,
"The grace of the Lord Jesus Christ and
the love of God and the communion of the
Holy Spirit be with you all. Like a
winning team, each person of the Godhead
has a different role. They each have a
special relationship to humanity. God
the Father sustains and supports us. God
the Son saves us from uh from sin and
shows us a better way to live. God the
Holy Spirit guides us in the way of
righteousness. All three work together
for our salvation. In the doctrine of
the Trinity, we see God's love revealed.
The book of Jude mentions this teamwork.
Beloved, building yourselves up on your
most holy faith, praying in the Holy
Spirit, keep yourselves in the love of
God, looking for the mercy of our Lord
Jesus Christ unto eternal life. Like the
ultimate winning team, the Trinity works
together for you. They will do
everything possible to bring you to
salvation. I know your synergism
radar is just like about to blink out of
its case.
Like a teacher in school who gives her
all to help her students succeed, the
Trinity works together to make salvation
understandable. They want you to
experience salvation.
So they go on and say a few other things
here and the point being God's goal is
the salvation of all and God is these
three beings or persons who are working
in tandem toward one common goal and
that's what makes them one. Is that the
trinity?
No. I will say they use a lot of
Christianes in this this article. So
it's hard to detect. But when you go
back to the very first paragraph when
you're talking about a bunch of
different people trying to work together
for a common goal, that's kind of the
whole problem. We're saying, "Okay, then
that reflects uh polytheism, multiple
different gods trying to really it,"
this article took the the human level
and just brought it up one more plane of
existence. It's basically um all the
Greek mythology gods. They're just blown
up versions of man, right? They're
divine beings that are one persons and
then you have a bunch of different
divine beings.
Um so that's that's kind of the f like
you can just tell um their version of
God. This heavenly trio which they're
calling the trinity is just a bunch of
divine people running around trying to
do and they just do it better. And the
problem is the reason why these
analogies break down is because we're
talking about the God who sustains our
existence. We're asking the deeper
questions. What makes these analogies um
even possible to begin with? Um our
world is fashioned in a particular way
that God uh has spoke this world into
existence and it reflects him. And so
that's why I love the the the mystery of
the trinity. The one being revealed in
three divine persons. The three persons
are that one um God who exists. And it's
like, man, that totally transcends our
uh plane of existence. But we can
apprehend many of those truths uh
through God's word. So
yeah, and God is not a trio.
That's a a very different
I know that that makes people think
three. So therefore, that's kind of
synonymous with trinity. No. No. That's
not what the Christian church means by
that. And so the Adventist church needs
to stop using this language and just say
that they affirm their own concept,
which we're going to look at a paper
here. I want to play a clip first. This
is from one of my former professors. We
played this on the channel before,
folks. Um, but some of you probably
haven't seen this before. So, um, Jud,
if you end up watching this stream, um,
would love to have you on to the show to
talk about this specific topic. We've
talked about this in the past before.
You know my position on this. you know
what my response to this is. But for
people to see that I'm not just making
these things up, we're going to start by
playing a small clip from him giving a
lecture during a Trinity Symposium is
what they call it. It's on uh video or
Vimeo. Um and I want you to listen. This
is the introduction. He's segueing from
somebody who just previously gave a
presentation and did a Q&A. And he makes
a comment here at the beginning before
getting into his his lecture and talk,
which was more focused on the history of
7th Day Adventism, which is his
specialty, specifically Ellen White. But
I want you to pay very close attention.
We're going to play this a couple maybe
two times. It's it's like 45 seconds or
something like that. But this is from a
scholar in their own church describing
what they believe to be the Trinity.
Good afternoon.
I am Jud Lake. I'm a professor at
Southern Adventure University. My focus
is on Ellen White's studies and
preaching. Just a piggyback on uh the
the Q&A. You know, when you think about
tritheism, three gods, one God. To me,
it's it's very clear in the marriage
relationship. Go back to Genesis. One
flesh,
two individuals.
One flesh, two indiv individuals.
Imagine if
the the husband and wife were surgically
connected.
You'd have some problems. Imagine the
fights.
But there'd be less divorce because then
you'd have to have radical surgery. So,
how are they one flesh? They're one in
mind, in purpose, in in their
characters, in their life together.
One flesh, two individuals, one God,
three individuals. They're united in
their purpose, in their character, in
their mission.
Just to follow up on the Q&A,
what are your thoughts on that, my
friend?
Well, it's everything we're talking
about. You're taking an earthly analogy,
a a temporal plane uh state of affairs
and and imposing that on an an absolute
eternal reality. And you know, a
marriage does reflect aspects of the
Trinity and the gospel. But um but we we
see it taken to an extreme with what
he's doing because yes, we are we are
one in purpose um with our spouse. um we
come together as one with wanting to
glorify God in our lives but that in
itself does not point back to God. God
is three distinct persons that fully
share in that divine being. And so what
what I try to explain like marriage
reflects God in in some ways is uh a
husband and wife are equal, right? We're
both people. We're distinct humans but
one is not less like with you know when
people go read Ephesians chapter 5 uh
the wife is supposed to submit to her
husband. Submission does not mean lesser
in equality, lesser in being or
something like that. U no we are one. We
we are equal with who we are as people.
And this does reflect back to God and
his perfect unity because the father is
uh or the holy spirit is not less in his
being and quality than the father or the
son. The early church used the word
paracaresis, right? Because uh they're
always they're so close when in order to
talk about the father, it's always in
the context of the spirit and in the
sun. There's this eternal dance going
on. But that's the fundamental fl uh
folly um that your old professor um was
was taking a created u a a a created
example and imposing that on God who is
unchanging who always is right and
that's where you're going to fall into
problems.
Yeah. And even with the marriage analogy
which we're going to see another analogy
that they try to use and say well this
is biblical see it's biblical. Um but
again it's the old switcheroo on terms
and taking something and applying it to
um the being of God, who God is. Like
taking uh Adam and Eve being one in in
marriage and coming together as one and
then applying that to who God is
in his being from eternity past.
No, no, you're drawing something out of
that. That's not a correct parallel
there. Right.
So that is one. Next, I want to look at,
and this is probably going to be the
most that we've gone through this on
this channel. We've looked at portions
of this before, but tonight since we're
specifically talking about the Trinity,
this is a great time to talk about uh a
lot more of this. And this is a paper
from one of their scholars. Um I'm going
to actually share
the whole PDF here.
And this paper is called the quest for a
biblical trinity. Ellen White's heavenly
trio compared to the traditional
doctrine.
This is by Jerry Moon. Jerry Moon uh
brother is I believe the chair of church
history at one of the Adventist
seminaries here in Berian Springs,
Michigan, Andrews University. This paper
is actually from their journal of
Adventist Theological Society, which is
essentially a resource for them of their
scholars putting out scholarly work. So,
this isn't just some Joemo. This isn't
some person who doesn't know anything
about Adventism or is writing some sort
of because you can access their
university portal. And this isn't one of
those papers from some student that was
doing like a master's thesis. No, this
is from somebody who knows this system
and is essentially giving you here an
overview of how the position has evolved
in their movement. So, we're going to go
through this here. And folks, I want you
to pay very close attention here. We're
going to read a lot of stuff. I know
there's going to be a lot of reading,
but please, please, please follow along.
This is very very very important. So he
starts this paper. Let's look at this
introductory paragraph.
In 1846,
James White, which is Ellen White's
husband,
dismissed the dismissed the I know, poor
poor Dr. White, right?
Yeah. James White dismissed the
traditional doctrine of the Trinity as
the old unscriptural trinitarian creed.
one of their pioneers.
A century later at the 1946 World
Session of the General Conference of
Seventh Day Adventists, the denomination
that James White co-founded voted
official endorsement of a fundamental
belief statement that explicitly
professed belief in the notice he puts
it in quotes, trinity.
During the 60 years that have passed
since the action, a trinitarian view of
God has remained dominant among 7th Day
Adventists. Despite the general
awareness since uh Roy Gain, he's one of
their he was one of their scholars.
Since Roy Gain's thesis in 1963 that
most of the early adventist leaders were
non trinitarian
halt,
the founders of this movement were anti-
anti-rinitarians.
Was God behind this? The one of the
central claims of this movement,
brother, is that they are restoring
apostolic Christianity.
That they are the end times remnant
church that God has called together at
this time in this per in this way for
this purpose to be a people for this
time to take a unique special miss or
message to the world. Did God raise up a
bunch of anti-trinitarian heretics in
the 19th century to restore his church?
That just to me I I'm glad you're
covering this because just on its face,
I hope people are really hearing you
clearly like u the trinity is
foundational because it goes back to us
talking about John 8:24 like Jesus
identifies himself as the eternal I am.
And so people that have this this trio
that you know different beings it's like
well listen you don't have one creator
you have three creators that are united
in purpose. That's different. That's the
different Jesus altogether. So no uh
God's not going to use non-trinitarians
to somehow restore the gospel.
Especially anti-trinitarians who are
espousing heresy that God gave a funeral
service to hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of years before
this movement even came together. But
look at the footnote here, folks. The
footnotes in these papers are so
important because you're oftent times
reading a compilation paper of a bunch
of compiled footnotes.
So the the part he mentions at the end
there, despite the general awareness
since uh Roy Gain's master's thesis in
1963 that most of the early adventist
leaders were non-rinitarian, people have
tried to fight this. There are people in
their movement who the the pro-heavenly
trio side that says no no no they've
always been that way. They've always
affirmed the tr the trinity.
He says here Leroy Froom he was one of
the uh the presidents of the general
conference um back in the day which is
the highest position you can get to in
their church. It's not like Mormonism
where he like is a prophet but it's the
highest position in their organization.
So in his movement of destiny on page
148 through 180 he breaks this down and
says although Froom's this is Jerry Moon
now commenting as he cited Froom he says
although Froom's pleading on the basis
of Millerat statistics that a majority
of the Adventist founders were
trinitarian that's not been supported by
the evidence.
So yes, the early which I have the
source documentation on this Uriah
Smith, these guys were not trinitarians.
They were coming from the Christian
Connection which came out of what was
called the res the uh it's not they were
a part of the restorationist movement
but it was more than that. It was an
actual organization called the
restorationist.
That was a movement prior to Millerism
and prior to the Christian connection.
The Christian connection was born out of
that and then people from the Christian
connection joined Millerism which then
joined 7th day Adventism
and they brought their christoologgical
heresies with them. So no, they were not
trinitarians.
So now he's going to explain to us what
the purpose of this paper is. He gives
some some stuff here in the
introduction. Uh just one second here. I
was down there and then I missed it. So
he's going to tell us the the purpose of
of the paper. So I'm going to read and
then we'll get back into it. So he says
the purpose of the present article is to
clarify more fully the similarities and
differences between Ellen White's view
of the heavenly trio and the traditional
doctrine of the trinity. That's what we
just discussed earlier in order to
discover her position in relation to the
current debate amongst Adventists. And
then he lists a number of their their
scholars. But he says, "However, the
unique position of Ellen White in the
Adventist church justifies taking her as
an authentic representative of Adventist
theology."
The conceptual key to unlock the puzzle
of Ellen White's developmental process
regarding the Godhead is the discovery
that her writings describe at least two
distinct varieties of Trinitarian
belief.
one based on scripture alone and one
based on scripture as interpreted
through the lens of Greek philosophy,
the same hermeneutic that brought the
immortality of the soul into Christian
theology. So you're going to quickly see
here, brother,
Greek mythology, Greek philosophy,
Aristotilian thought, these are always
the boogeyman for the Adventist church.
That's always the fall guy for them.
They're like the Sinians in this regard.
Oh, the church went apostate right after
the apostles because it corrupted itself
with Greek paganism and mythology and
and they all all those Yeah. Athanasius,
Irenaeus, uh, Cyprien, they were all
heretics because they were pagan Greek
mythologists. That's sort of the thing
because you have to downplay them
because when all of Christian history is
against you, you have to find some
conspiracy obviously to silence all of
that.
So, when it comes to the Sabbath, just
everything, it's always a conspiracy.
because none of history is in line with
them. But he continues saying, "The
concept of God that is explicit in her
later writings portrays the father, son,
and holy spirit as three eternal persons
of intellect, will, and emotions who are
united in character, purpose, and love.
We're going to get into this term person
later.
There is no conflict among them, no
working at cross purposes, no
competition, not even disagreement. Thus
they are not three gods as in polytheism
or tritheism but one. So this is why I
asked you earlier Deuteronomy 6:4 what
did the Jews Christians early Christians
Jesus understand by the term they are
the Lord our God is one because they're
going to appeal to that here for example
and say well they were one in their
mission purpose and character. That's
what's being referred to in in the
schma. The Israelites understood we're
worshiping three beings who are one in
their mission, purpose, and character.
Is that what makes them one?
No. And I think I mean, you could
probably approach this a number of
different ways, but this is referring to
the one creator God who knows no other.
And so it's to try to say then because
what they're really pushing is there's
three creators that are one in purpose.
And that flies in the face of of all of
scripture, but that that's what you're
looking at. I mean, they are worshiping
the creator who is distinct from all of
his creation. So when they're quoting
the shama, they're giving the reverence
and honor to the creator of God of all
things who shares his glory with no one
by the way.
Yes. So before moving on in the article,
couple things again. He says Ellen White
is an authority on this. Ellen White
presents two distinct Trinity concepts.
He says one that's supposedly influenced
by Greek philosophy that's supposed to
be you and I, Jeremiah. Oh,
and their heavenly trio concept, which
is supposedly the truly biblical one. So
question, is our ancient belief in the
Trinity not derived with scriptural
presuppositions? Because that's the
argument they're going to make is that
you're using Greek presuppositions.
We're using biblical presuppositions. Is
that the case?
No. Because when we are defining being,
we're talking about existence. We're
talking about essence. What makes
something exist truly? And we're saying
and then everything that exists is very
peculiarly uh unified in some way. And
yet we're distinct. And so then we start
talking about some of those
distinctions. This is impersonal, right?
And so you and I are distinct persons,
but we have separate beings, right? And
so when we look at scripture, we see
there's one God who eternally exists. Uh
he's unchanging. He's simple, which I'm
sure they would hate us using that type
of language, but he's one in essence,
but he is revealed in three divine
distinct persons.
Yes.
It's also bogus. So when he claims they
read the Bible with no lens, just
scripture as it is, yet their same
scholars, and folks, I've showed this on
the channel plenty of times, also admit
that the great controversy theme, which
was given to them, not something they
they found from scripture, something
they admit, Herbert Douglas says was
given to them.
And it it's how they interpret all of
scripture. So, we're only using biblical
presuppositions even though we have this
thing called the great controversy
theme, which is the lens through which
we read all of scripture.
It's a good point.
No, folks, you're kidding yourselves.
But again, he he says that Ellen White
is an authentic representative of
Adventist theology. So, now with that in
mind, before moving forward in the
article, he's going to get into some in
here, but I want to get into some
different ones. I want to read some of
her statements regarding the heavenly
trio.
This is what they're telling the world
is the trinity. And this is why there
are people who are confused. I mean,
man, you have like I know some of the
guys over at Catholic Answers. They have
an article on there where they're like,
"Well, Adventists are basically
trinitarian." Now, the guys at Catholic
Answers, if they heard this stuff
tonight, they'd go, "Whoa, never mind."
They're simply using the word Trinity.
Quote, this is from Patriarchs and
Prophets, one of the big three, page 34.
The sovereign of the universe was not
alone in his work of beneficence as the
father. He had an associate, a co-orker
who could appreciate his purposes and
could share his joy in giving happiness
to created beings. Christ the word, the
only begotten of God, was one with the
eternal father, one in nature, okay, in
character and in purpose. The only being
that could enter into all the councils
and purposes of God. Close quote.
Is Jesus a separate being from the
father?
No. And this I mean this gets into the
whole song and dance that we've been
doing. Um that's that's unique to the
trinity. So when we get accused of being
pagan, I'm like show me another
definition of one being multi-personal.
I mean it doesn't exist anywhere.
Yeah. But also too, if Jesus is the only
being that could enter into all the
councils, what does that say about the
Holy Spirit?
Right. I mean,
well, this is because it's this is
because it's coming from a time period,
which he's going to talk about this
later.
They didn't believe the Holy Spirit was
a person at this point.
They thought the Holy Spirit was the the
presence of the Father and the Son in
their physical absence of being there
in their physical absence.
Well, yeah, and you're going to see why
I say that uh here in in in a little
bit. Next quote. Testimonies for the
Church, Volume 8, page 268.
Quote, "God is the Father of Christ.
Christ is the son of God. To Christ has
been given an exalted position. He has
been made equal with the father. All the
councils of God are open to his son.
Is that compatible with trinitarianism,
brother?
No. No. But but it's trying to confuse
the categories of um the incarnation and
Christ's exaltation. So Jesus
condescended,
right? He um he veiled his divine
prerogatives. um truly taking on man. So
so I'm just saying when you have that
category then you can look at verses
where Jesus says not my will will be
done but your will be done to the
father. He prays to the father who is
greater than myself. Jesus says
positionally but not in terms of deity.
Yes.
Again with that quote too um all the
councils of God are open to his son.
Where's the Holy Spirit in all of this?
Where is he? Another quote, Spirit of
Prophecy, Volume 1, page 17.
Quote, "The great creator assembled the
heavenly host that he might in the
presence of all the angels confer
special honor upon his son." This is
before the creation of the earth, by the
way. The son was seated on the throne
with the father, and the heavenly throne
of holy angels was gathered around them.
The father then made known that it was
ordained by himself that Christ his son
should be equal with himself. So that
wherever was the presence of his son, it
was as his own presence. Close quote.
Jesus was not made equal with the father
and given omnipresence.
Right?
If Jesus does not possess all of the
divine attribution, he is not God.
Right? You can't in what you're going to
find with this heavenly trio is that
well it's like well the it's really more
like tritheistic monarchianism and I
know those are kind of big words but
like for those that don't know
monarchianism is the idea that well the
father is the almighty the son is the
next and then the the the spirit right
there's a hierarchy with with the father
being the almighty alone it's kind of
like that but tritheistic
right
as well it's a it's a weird amalgamation
here So, those are just a couple of
things that Ellen White herself said,
which is where they're getting this idea
of the Trinity or their concept of what
they call the Trinity from.
She also had a lot of free time to dream
up a lot of this stuff
that and she was a pretty good
plagiarizer. Um, she play she she
plagiarized a lot and and didn't um she
had no business claiming to speak for
God and claiming to uh be able to tell
us what God was describing about
himself, etc. um let alone saying that
she needed to correct everyone else that
was um wrong and they were the ones that
were correct in restoring things. So he
continues he says furthermore their
unity is not a mathematical paradox but
a relational unity analogous to the
unity seen in a good marriage. So that's
where Jud is getting this from
where husband and wife are united in an
ever growing oneness but without
negating their individual individuality.
Are you seeing how they're
interchangeably using person and being?
Yeah. Yeah. 100%. And how did he word
it? Mathematical impossibility. What did
you say?
Yeah. He said, furthermore,
their unity is not a mathematical
paradox,
but a relational unity analogous to the
unity seen in a good marriage where
husband and wife are united in an
everrowing oneness, but without negating
their individuality.
Right? Well, there's not a mathematical
paradox or problem or contradiction when
you understand the two distinct
categories that we are talking about now
being in personhood. Uh but like you're
saying, the seventh day Adventist are
just conflating those two
interchangeable with one another and
then they are the ones with the problems
on their hands.
Yes. Now we're going to see the schma
like we mentioned earlier.
Yes.
So he says, "Thus her concept is in
harmony with the biblical witness of
both the old and new testaments." So
remember what he was just talking about
was this relational unity of being one
like a marriage.
Sure.
After God said, "Let us make man in our
image," Genesis 1:26-27,
God proceeded to create humans in a
plurality of forms that were capable of
becoming one.
Did you catch that?
Oh, yeah.
In Genesis 2:24, God explained his
purpose in this. So that these diverse
creatures bearing his image, there's a
reason he puts that in quotes,
could become one. The Hebrew word
translated one in Genesis 2:24 is which
you mentioned earlier. Not a monolithic
singleness for which Moses could have
used,
one or only, but a unity formed from
multiple components. The same word
occurs in Deuteronomy 6:4.
Is Deuteronomy 6:4 saying that what
makes God one is there is a plurality of
beings who are one in a mission? No. So
earlier where we read um that these
diverse creatures bearing his image
could become one. So this is where you
have to always retain the distinction
between creator and creation because God
is not becoming. He is not in flux. God
is aay. He is self-existent. He is
eternally existent. So he doesn't change
is my point. And so that's that's to me
is the biggest problem when you're
trying to look at um a marriage to
onetoone um univically with the creator
of saying oh well this is how uh the the
divine trio or heavenly trio works. It's
like, no, I do agree that a husband and
wife come together um one in purpose in
a very wonderful way um to glorify God
together. But you can't take that
principle of where two human beings are
becoming one in a profound sense um to
then try to talk about how God is
becoming one in purpose. No, God God is
eternally one in his existence um and in
his essence. interchangeable terms. Uh
but they are three distinct persons. So
does that make sense that God is not
becoming anything? He simply is.
Yes. And it's it's wrong to take an
analogy like this where something is
being said it's conflation. Well, we
have an example here of them becoming
one. So we can now apply that to God's
ontos.
Exactly.
And because it's it's bib it's there in
the Bible that we're biblical in doing
that. Well, no. You're just wrongfully
using the scriptures to now apply that
wrongfully to a category. You're making
a category error.
Right.
The way that two human beings come
together and become one in marriage is
not how God is.
Yeah. And when I was studying uh John
Frame, I mean, he really drove home the
point the the distinction between
creator and creation. You have to
understand we do not exist in the same
way. We are created. We are contingent.
We are derivative. God is eternally
existent. And I love the verse at the
Aropagus in Acts 17. It talks about in
him, in God, we live and move and have
our being. In his light, we see light.
So that's why we are imagebearers. We
reflect many of the communicable
attributes of our creator, right? It
gets through. That's why we're actually
able to relate to him um analogically.
That's a that's a big word. Uh but God
God meets us where we're at, right? He
speaks to us in baby talk, so to speak.
Yes.
But the thing is, you can't take human
categories and univically one to one
place that on the eternal creator. And
so that's why we stay away from created
analogies in Toto saying that that's how
the the heavenly trio is. You got these
three beings working together, one in
purpose. And that's that's how God is
one, Miles.
Yeah, I know. So, he continues here and
he says that that was good, by the way.
Sorry. I wasn't just trying to dismiss
what you were saying. Um,
he says, "The concept of plurality of
persons in unity of relationship becomes
more explicit in the New Testament." So,
now we get another analogy that's being
wrongfully applied to who God is. For
example, Christ prayed that believers in
him may all be one as he and the father
are one. John 17:20-22.
Ellen White quotes this passage as proof
of the quote personality of the father
and the son. Again, we're going to get
into this term person and the way they
define it and an explanation of the
unity that exists between them. She
wrote, "The unity that exists between
Christ and his disciples does not
destroy the personality of either. They
are one in purpose, in mind, in
character, but not in person. It is thus
that God and Christ are one."
In the same year, 1905, she wrote
elsewhere, "There are three living
persons of the heavenly trio. the
Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Her concept of the heavenly trio differs
from the traditional trinity and that
it's based on simple biblical reasoning
and biblical presuppositions.
Then we've got the footnote here. The
fact that scripture has much more to say
about the relational unity of God does
not preclude God's ontological unity,
but the ontological unity is certainly
less explicit in scripture.
That's the opposite.
So,
yeah.
did you notice he admitted
their view is not historic orthodox
Christian trinitarianism? That's
supposedly Greek paganism built on Greek
presuppositions and their concept is
truly the biblical one,
right?
So, why are they using the term trinity?
Well, I think it's kind of the whole
point of your ministry is they are
trying to pretend to be Christian, but
in in a deeper sense really to get
Christians to join them, right? They're
they're the remnant. They're the ones
with the secret knowledge that you need
to be made right with God through
keeping the Sabbath and the the rest of
the commandments and so forth.
Yeah.
Um
so he Oh, go ahead.
I was going to make one point. I won't I
won't get super deep into this, but like
in John 17, this is a profound prayer.
Jesus is a high priestly prayer. And
there is a sense we get to share in the
the unity of God. And I would say in his
purpose, in his eternal will, we get to
share in that in that relationship with
God. But even when we reach glory, we
will still be creatures who are
glorified, right?
Yeah.
And I'm just saying like without going
super deep into it, but but John 17 u
highly truly trinitarian language where
um Jesus talks about being restored to
the glory that he had with the father
before the foundation of the world. And
when you go back to the prophet Isaiah,
um he explains in chapter 42, the one
God, the creator God who shares his
glory with no other. Well, Jesus is
talking about that glory that he shares
with the father. He was an eternal
relationship, face-to-face relationship
with father in perfect glory. And when
you know I was talking to Brandt Bosman
when we say where where were they in the
context of the spirit, the spirit
eternally was there with them in perfect
glory. But that is the one true creator
Yahweh God who shares his glory this
triune God with no other.
Amen.
So he continues in this by saying
in maintaining that the father and the
son are two now notice the air quotes
two distinct literal tangible persons.
James White certainly did not doubt that
God is spirit. John 4:24.
But he insisted that though spiritual
beings, Christ and the father are
nevertheless divine persons who have a
quote literal tangible existence. They
are neither unreal nor imaginary.
You'll notice that oftentimes what they
mock the idea that Christians believe in
spiritual realities and spiritual beings
as being unreal and imaginary
because this gets into their
physicalism, their monism that really
what is true and what is real is that
which has organic physical matter. Um
different stream for a different time.
Actually just did a stream on this for
those that are curious. You can look on
the channel. It's within the last couple
weeks or so. But um the trinitarian
creeds he knew of James White made God
so abstract, theoretical, and impersonal
that God was no longer perceived as a
real, caring, loving being. For example,
one trinitarian creed that the early
adventist quoted fairly often was that
of the the Methodist Episcopal Church.
Their creed is actually based off of um
those of the likes of the Westminster
Confession, etc.
uh Ellen White's Church of Origin, that
creed says in part, "There is but one
living God, living and true God,
everlasting without body or parts." This
the early Adventists vigorously refuted,
citing several biblical passages that
portrayed God as having both body and
parts.
So before we get into that aspect,
does the father possess a physical
tangible form?
No. Um I mean that the verse references
up there John 4:24, God is spirit.
So I mean you know with the the trinity
concept we can understand that God being
tripal has been eternally spirit not
physical but it's God the son that took
on flesh stepped into creation. So to to
kind of blur those lines and to make God
into having parts um is is literally
cutting up the being. Right? That's why
we classically talk about God being
simple. He is um God is not comprised of
parts like man like created man physical
man.
Yeah. And what the church means by that
is that um well a couple things like you
mentioned God does not have like two
ears and a mouth and a nose. These
different parts that can be broken up.
He is not a complex being.
He is a simple being.
Yep. But furthermore, you also have
being stated in this claim is that God
is not like 20% love, 10% vengeance, 5%
this. His attribution is not parted out
either.
He is like he he is love. He is
merciful. He is wrathful. He is all
these different attributes. And it's not
like there's a caricature. And by that I
mean one is just overshadowing the rest
of them.
That's what's being said by that. Yet
these pioneers disagreed with this
because in their minds they thought,
well, if God doesn't have a physical
body like I have, how can he be
relatable?
Right?
That's not what this creed was getting
at. Even though obviously they would say
that no, God does not have a physical
being. But the Adventist pioneers took
this to mean, well, then he's not
personal. M
and that's not what was being said at
all at all. So they yeah they they
didn't understand what was being said
but really it shows us that the
Adventist heavenly trio is a complex set
of beings.
Yep.
That are made up of parts that can
apparently be divided. They were
vehematly against the Christian belief
about divine simplicity. So he continues
here.
He says twice in early visions of Jesus,
she asked him, this is Ellen White now,
questions related to the form and person
of God. So this is what's informing
their definitions of terms when they
tell you, oh, it's we're just deriving
it from the Bible. He even admits in
this paper that no, they actually it's
another paper on this. Um he he admits
that they derived their final
understandings of things. They'll claim
through scripture, but then Ellen White
is also listed. That's where it's
ultimately coming from. Twice in early
visions of Jesus, she asked him
questions related to the form and person
of God. In one early vision, she
reported seeing a throne and on it sat
the Father and the Son. I gazed on
Jesus's countenance, she said, and
admired his lovely person. The Father's
person I could not behold. For a cloud
of glorious light covered him. I asked
Jesus if his father had a form like
himself. He said he had, but I could not
behold it. For said he, if you should
once behold the glory of his person, you
would cease to exist. I've often Oh, and
then in 1850 she reported, I've often
seen the lovely Jesus, that he is a
person. I asked him if his father was a
person and had a form like himself. Said
Jesus, I'm in the express image of my
father's person. Thus, her visions
confirmed what her husband had written
in 1846, that the father and the son are
two distinct, literal, tangible persons.
The visions also disproved to her mind
the claim of the Methodist creed that
God is without parts or or body or
parts. Thus, these early visions steered
her developing view of God away from
creedal trinitarianism, though they
offered nothing directly contradictory
to her later statements of what I have
called biblical trinitarianism.
So, what does that statement tell you
about that that first part real quick?
Yeah. the the the tangible persons. Like
to me, they're conflating categories. Uh
because we're big
persons. Um you you can't put persons in
a jar and examine it. Um this is the
immaterial aspect of humanity, right?
Our soul, right?
They don't they don't believe in that.
Oh, well, you got me there. Um I'd have
to call you if if they if I was like, I
can't help you.
Yeah. This is their monism. Um they
think that your your soul is basically
just a combination of breath and a body
and when the breath leaves the body the
soul no longer exists.
Do they so what do they do with mind?
What do they think mind is?
Well it depends who you talk to. Um
that's kind of getting into a side
discussion. Maybe we'll get into that at
some other time. But I want to focus in
on this this beginning part because
there's one big thing here. The key
thing.
What does the statement at the beginning
tell you about the Adventist Jesus in
relation to the father? She could behold
Jesus and see him, but the father was
too majestic and glorious.
They're they're distinct, right,
radically um from one another. It sounds
like uh just different beings. And so
kind of proving our our point all night
long.
Well, and not just that, but the
demotion of Jesus like he's not as
glorious as the father.
Right. Right. No, that's good.
I could behold him, but not the father.
Boo.
Which if you read her writings in tot um
at great length on this specific topic,
you're going to constantly see this sort
of monarchianism.
The father is better. The father is more
powerful. He's the almighty. He's the
Lord God Almighty. That sort of stuff.
So that's a huge blunder right there.
Plus on top of that, it's BS. She did
not talk to Jesus.
But then he but then he he rightly
recognizes that they rejected again
credle trinitarianism showcasing that
they are borrowing Christian terminology
but redefining it through what Ellen
White has supposedly claimed regarding
scripture.
That's what's going on here. And there's
a conflation of the term one going on by
using the disciples as an example of
actually of of being and na and the
nature of God like applying to that. But
then I want to look at the footnote here
really quick. Again, footnote.
You got to pay attention to the
footnotes, man.
100%.
Jesus prayed that his disciples might be
one as he is one with his father. This
prayer did not contemplate
Yeah. This prayer did not contemplate
one disciple with 12 heads, but 12
disciples made one in object and effort
in the cause of their master. Neither
are the father and the son parts of the
three one God. They are two distinct
beings.
Yet one in the design of accomplishment
of redemption.
Right.
That's from James White, Ellen White's
husband.
So unfortunate his name's James White.
Yeah. So again, is that compatible what
James White said with trinitarianism?
No, it's confirming what you've you've
pointed out. They are using person and
being interchangeably. And then we're
emphasizing when you divide the beings,
you have multiple gods.
And the the the heavenly trio is not
monotheistic, right? It's polytheistic.
Yes. So he continues here in her first
volume titled spiritual gifts, which
we've looked at on the channel before.
Her belief in the Holy Spirit is not in
question, for she refers to the Father,
the Son, and the Holy Spirit in Christ's
baptismal narrative. But she does not
mention the Holy Spirit in connection
with the divine councils about creation
and salvation.
But because of their ambiguity, get
this, they could be read without
conflict by Adventists regardless of
both trinitarian and anti-trinitarian
leanings.
Did you catch that? I mentioned that
earlier. No mention of the Holy Spirit
being able to be let into these
councils.
He says though that is the case, there's
enough ambiguity where both sides of the
of our people in this movement can
support their views with the claim. So
that's what makes it okay.
You can be an anti-trinitarian heretic
in this movement, man. It is crazy. It's
absolutely crazy. But you can't be
anything other than a premillennialist
historicist.
So you can't be saved if you deny like
premillennialism wholesale.
Well, no, no, you have to believe
premillennial historicism
because their whole system is predicated
on esquetology.
So if you disagree with their
esquetology, their whole system
collapses. So unlike the Christian faith
where it's like you can be an
amillennial p you know predtoist or
partial predtoist um futurist there's
room for these within orthodoxy because
at the end of the day for example if I'm
wrong on my view of the mark of the
beast my whole system doesn't collapse
right
my whole system isn't predicated upon
every aspect of my esquetology being
correct that's not the case for this
movement
right
all of their esquetology has to be
correct at every step of the way or the
whole thing falls apart which is another
red flag of the system being super super
weak.
And this just goes back to what you've
been saying. They're trying to appeal to
Christians that are trinitarian
um unitarian. It's like, "Hey, you can
come join us. No big deal." And yet I'm
saying to to misunderstand who Jesus is
and who God is is the difference of
heaven and hell, salvation and being
lost according to Jesus, according to
the Apostle Paul who warns us about
false Jesus's, right?
Yes, in in 2 Corinthians, we mentioned
that earlier. 2 Corinthians 11 1-4.
So, we skip down a little bit here a few
pages
and then we got to get into now what she
says here defining
the truth about the Godhead as they call
it.
Folks, I'll link to this paper by the
way in the description box. This is a
PDF that I've downloaded and had on my
computer for quite some time now. Um, so
I'm not able to share the link in the
description or in the the live chat, but
I will add this for those that want to
read the whole thing. It's not too
terribly long. Um, but these are the
main things we wanted to look at
specifically tonight. So, um, here he
says, then she defines what she
understands to be the truth about the
godhead.
The Father is all, this is him quoting
now, of course,
the Father is all the fullness of the
Godhead bodily
and is invisible to mortal sight.
So, he has a physical tangible form, but
he's invisible to mortal sight. And he's
the fullness of the Godhead bodily.
How is physical, tangible matter
invisible?
And she's misquing Colossians 2:9,
right, with saying that is the father.
Yeah. But what she means by that is that
she's talking about how they all have a
physical tangible form. So they're all
the fullness of the Godhead bodily. It
goes back to being three beings, three
persons.
The Son is all the fullness of the
Godhead manifested.
The word of God declares him to be the
express image of his person. God so
loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son that whosoever believeth in
him should not perish but have
everlasting life. Here in Christ is
shown the personality of the father.
Remember how they're using the term
personality.
She just broke their own standard,
right? I thought they were radically and
tangibly different persons and now she's
saying that Jesus is the personality of
the father. Right.
So this is what he's saying about how
this woman evolved on this. Yet all of
her words are barricaded by a thus
sayeth the Lord. Her writings were are
are authored by the same author of the
scriptures, she said, which is the Holy
Spirit.
Yet they have to deal with this
evolution of God's supposed messenger
evolving on her position of like the
most cardinal foundational established
doctrine of the Christian faith.
The comforter
that Christ promised to send after his
ascension to heaven is the spirit in all
the fullness of the Godhead making
manifest the power of divine grace to
all who receive and believe in Christ as
a personal savior. There are three
living persons of the heavenly trio in
the name of these three great powers.
The father, the son, and the holy
spirit. Those who receive Christ by
living faith are baptized. And these
powers will cooperate with the obedient
subjects of heaven in their efforts to
live the new life in Christ.
Is the Godhead three powers?
No.
For I'm I'm just
leaving leaving emphasis there. Yeah.
The silence for emphasis. And then want
to throw in our our good friend Isaac
Latuni.
Did he say that?
There you go.
Yes, he did say that because he's
quoting from Ellen White.
No, God is not three powers, folks.
There is one almighty.
This is not the right language to be
using. This is this the language of
somebody who has no business claiming
that they never wrote a single sentence
of heresy.
That the words in their books are
barricaded by a thus sayeth the Lord.
Yes, we're going to be super critical on
a person like this Adventist. When you
comment on my videos and try and
downplay or act like I'm going
overboard, no, I'm not. This person
claimed to speak for God, claimed to
have over 2,000 visions, claims to be
the last human being that talked with
Jesus face to face. And the first thing
she thought to ask Almighty God when
talking with him, even though she
doesn't believe he's the Almighty, is,
"Does your father have a form like you
do?
Yes, we're going to drill on this hard.
The standard is set very high. She had
zero business
talking about this and claiming that
this is now correcting the Christian
church who supposedly has been apostate
and is being restored by them.
Yeah. No thanks.
Yet they didn't understand that the Holy
Spirit was even a person until well, as
you're going to see here, she clearly
rejected any view of the Trinity that
makes God impersonal and unreal. So our
view is is making him unreal. That's
what they mean by this. But embraced a
literal biblical view of one God and
three eternal persons who are
relationally united in character,
purpose, and love. Again, same thing. So
now in the summary of this section, he
kind of recaps some of the things we
just talked about. He says this change
from Adventist rejection of the trin of
the of the traditional doctrine of the
trinity to acceptance of a biblical
trinitarian doctrine was not a simple
reversal. When James White denounced
creedole trinitarianism in 1846, Ellen
White agreed with both his positive
point that the father and the son are
two distinct literal tangible persons
and his negative point that the
philosophical trinitarianism held by
many did spiritualize away the personal
reality of the father and the son aka it
says they don't have physical tangible
forms. Soon after this, she added the
conviction based on visions that both
Christ and the father have bodily form,
rejecting the teaching of one of one
trinitarian creed that God is without
body or parts. In 1890s, in the 1890s,
when she became convinced of the
individuality and personhood of the Holy
Spirit, so the Holy Spirit has a
physical tangible form, too. She
referred to the Holy Spirit in literal
and tangible terms much like those she
had used in 1850 to describe the father
and the son.
Remind me something real quick because I
know it was earlier in the article, but
what is their explanation that God is
spirit?
Yeah. So, they just essentially state
that. I covered this in a stream uh
about their physicalism um about a week
and a half or so ago. So, people can
check that out if they want. It's called
physicalism uh the adventist pioneers
the and the the image of God and the
trinity and we looked at James White
Ellen White's husband uh his his book
called the personality of God where he
talks about this and quotes this and he
mentioned it in passing earlier but he
didn't go into great detail. They
essentially dismiss spirit as being uh
unreal and fake. So they'll say, "Well,
we believe that God is spirit, but at
the same time, spirit is truly partaking
of some sort of physical tangible
like us like like man." Yeah. Yeah.
That's the folly they're doing. This is
just like Greek mythology. This sounds
so much like Mormonism. It's not even
funny.
Yeah. So that's why they will say man
being made in the image of God means
that it's what we physically look like,
right?
And it's three of those.
That's why if you look at the Adventist
art and stuff like that, angels, for
example, are depicted as human beings
with wings
because it's the stereotypical
angel that Ellen White claimed to see
when she went to heaven supposedly.
Sure. Say Morona.
Yeah, I know. Yeah. Um just like Joseph
Smith.
So then he says again, in the same year
she defined their unity. This is 1905.
So 10 years before her death, she was
still saying this is how they are
united. In relational rather than
philosophical terms, the uni quote the
unity that exists between Christ and his
disciples does not destroy the
personality of either. They are one in
purpose, in mind, and in character, but
not in person. It is thus that God and
Christ are one. Since Ellen White
clearly held the basic the basic formula
of one God and three persons, it can
hardly be denied that her view is
essentially trinitarian. However, her
views differ from traditional
trinitarianism in the following
important aspects. I or respects. I love
this line and I laugh every time I come
across it because I love how he's like
basically just trying to sweeten the
well before he now just opens the
floodgates of how it's literally nothing
like like it's nothing like
trinitarianism. But he he has to start
off by saying it's essentially the same
thing. However, here's how it disagrees.
And then we're going to look at all of
these differences. But notice something
here, Jeremiah. I caught this earlier
and I hadn't caught this before and I
went, "Wow, of course." Because this is
always the case.
Did you notice a word that he used in
that final paragraph there?
Essentially,
why don't they like to talk about the
being of God? Well, they'll tell you
that's Greek presuppositions to talk
about the essence or the substance.
Yet here he's okay with using Greek
language and says, "Well, their position
is essentially
trinitarian."
Ah, okay. So, it's okay to use these
terms when you want to use the terms and
not call everyone else a pagan
presuppositionalist.
It's good.
Just a little uh recognition there,
folks. That's what we're saying when
we're talking about the being. We're
talking about the essence. But he won't
allow us to apply that in the context of
God's being. But it's okay for them to
say in essence we're basically
trinitarians.
That's good
thoughts on that before we get into the
ways that she uh completely actually
rejects as you've already seen.
No, I mean I've kind of I feel like a
broken record a little bit. I mean
they're just they're abusing the
categories of what we mean. accusing us
of being pagan, being Greek, which is
blowing my mind because I hope everybody
sees they're just taking man and then
just putting it on a higher divine
plane. That's what Greek mythology does.
That's what Mormonism does. They are the
ones that are pagan getting literally
these ideas are not original with LG
Watt and these people.
No. So now he's going to go into the
ways that it is different. So now we're
going to pivot and it won't be as much
of a broken record, but I think it's
good that we're hammering these kind of
same things over and over and showing
that it's over and over and over again.
So here he says, so one, and he's going
to state multiple things in here.
She rejected at least three of the
philosophical presuppositions
undergirling traditional trinitarianism.
A, the radical dualism. This will answer
your question earlier about John 4:24.
The radical dualism of spirit and matter
which concluded that God could not have
a visible form.
B. The notion of impassibility
which held that God has no passions,
feelings or emotions, hence could not
have or could have no interest in or
sympathy with humans. and C the dualism
of time and timelessness which led to
the notions of eternal generation and
eternal procession. Her rejection of all
of these concepts constitutes a radical
departure from the medieval dogma of the
trinity. So in essence they're
trinitarian but it's a radical departure
right
from trinitarianism
essentially not.
Yeah. So there's a number of things I
want to look at here because he he
mentions a number of things. Um, I want
to let you say whatever you want to say
before I get into to these things
because then we're going to look at
another source because we have to read
the footnote here and I'm going to
defend our Christian brothers um from
times past because it bothers me the way
that they slander them. So, thoughts on
all of that and then I'll have some
stuff.
Um, I just I want to echo what we've
been saying about we have to have the
distinction the creator creation
distinction. So we're saying the way
that father, son, and spirit relates to
one another, this is in a divine eternal
category. So how we relate to one
another, it's not going to be one to one
the way that God is eternally
relational. Because I can understand how
some people with the impassibility get
confused on that. Um, we look at many
scriptures about God grieving. Well,
this is man's attempt. This is Moses's
attempt to describe what he's observing
with God. And like I said, he he is
above us. He is uh set apart. We are
merely made in his image. So, you know,
a lot can be said with those things. I'm
at least glad to see in this document
that they are trying to like they at
least understanding where true trinit
trinitarians lie. And so, they're trying
to figure out how to just redefine a
number of things and depart in small
ways to still try to sell. Well, at the
end of the day, we're still
trinitarians.
Yeah.
So, I want to read the footnote here and
then I'm going to have a number of
things to to share because we're going
to get into some of these things like
impassibility, their wrong understanding
of what's being said, um, etc. But it
says here, Roger Olsson, he used to be
the director of the Ellen White estate
back in I think like the late 80s, early
90s, somewhere around in there, but he's
also a historian in the Adventist
church. Roger Olsson, a historian of
theology, summarizes this situation.
Augustine's God,
though trinitarian,
is made captive to the Greek
philosophical theology of divine
simplicity, immutability, and
impassibility, and turns out to be more
like a great cosmic emperor than a
loving, compassionate heavenly father.
Halt, I saw you throw your head back.
No, I'm just I'm just listening. Go
ahead.
Well, no, I'm perfect timing because I
wanted Halt because of this.
Okay. I've brought this out on the
channel before and I didn't have the the
receipts on hand at the time handy to be
able to just pull out.
I have City of God here.
I'm going to bring it up digitally so
people can see. I want you to remember
this
because then I'm going to have a
question for you. Uh oh. Remember the
claim is that Augustine's God because of
the way that Augustine understood God
was more like a cosmic emperor,
not one who was compassionate. Which is
what he goes on next to say because he
says Anselum, which we're going to read
Anselm too. He says Anselm denied that
God experiences feelings of compassion
at all.
So I'm going to read an excerpt here.
This is one small excerpt out of a big
book, The City of God. And then I'll
have a question for you. Does this sound
like a cosmic emperor to you?
This is from chapter 21 or book 21 for
those that are curious, chapter 15,
where he's specifically talking about
the grace of God.
He says, "For the Lord knoweth them that
are his, and as many as are led by the
spirit of God, they are sons of God."
Quoting scripture, but by grace and not
by nature.
For there is but one son of God by
nature,
who in his compassion
became son of man for our sakes, that we
by nature sons of men might by grace
become through him sons of God.
For he abiding unchangeable,
there's that immutability aspect,
but yet he's talking about compassion
and stuff as well. took upon him our
nature
that thereby he might take us to himself
and holding fast his own divinity.
He didn't affirm the kosis heresy of
Philippians 26 through8 fully God fully
man.
He became partaker of our infirmity.
That we being changed into some better
thing might by participating in his
righteousness and immortality
lose our own properties of sin and
mortality and preserve whatever good
quality he had implanted in our nature
perfected now by sharing in the goodness
of his nature. For as by the sin of one
man we have fallen into a misery so
deplorable, so by the righteousness of
one man, who also is God, shall we come
to a blessedness inconceivably exalted.
So he gets into a lot of theology here.
He's talking about headship being
transferred, essentially what Paul's
talking about in Romans 5, being
transferred from the fallen family of
Adam into Christ. That there's only one
who is by nature son of God. The rest of
us are through that one brought into
God's family. And all of this is by
God's grace. It's by his compassion that
he does this. The idea that St.
Augustine viewed God as an impersonal
cosmic emperor who experienced no
emotion
shows that the scholars in this movement
have not read these people.
You're right. They are regurgitating and
pariting information that they have
heard from who knows where and it's
simply being passed down because then
people like Jed Lake read these papers
and they start regurgitating it. Like
the marriage analogy.
This is where they're getting these
things from folks. They haven't read
these things. It's absolute nonsense to
say that Augustine's God, his view of
God was impersonal. So my question for
you, brother,
why do we call the doctrines of grace
the doctrines of grace? Was Calvin
novely coming up with these things? Or
I'm going to ask somewhat of a
rhetorical question here, but then I
want to just hear your thoughts. Or were
Cal, if you read Calvin's Institutes,
are you gonna by proxy just read a lot
of Augustine?
Right. Right.
Yeah. So my initial thoughts are um
Ellen White people, you know, people um
just in that camp, they're really just
trying to bolster their case. Well, ours
is personal. Ours is the one that's
truly loving. Our our understanding of
the heavenly trio can ex u can show
compassion and grace, but not this, you
know, radical pagan trinitarian. And I
think you're right. I think it's obvious
they just don't read and they don't like
what's being said even if they are
reading to some degree. And we have to
understand the creator of creation
distinction because God God is though I
know that's grammatically not right but
he he is his attributes and so there's a
difference in us being loving right that
love can Wayne and can increase can
decrease but God is love um God is
compassion and so I think the folly once
again is they're just they're not they
don't like not being able to fully
comprehend God and his attributes from
all eternity. And what they're
necessarily doing and distorting God is
taking human categories of our re
reflection of God's attributes, right?
Those communicable attributes, but they
are pressing upon how we experience love
on to God, onto father, son, and spirit.
Uh and so that's just the same old song
and dance with Greek mythology. That's
what you have going on here.
Yeah. They're essentially saying unless
God is like I am, he can't be related
to.
They they are literally fashioning God
according to their image.
Totally. Well, now I want to read
Anselum because Roger Olsson in there
said that Anselum's God as well. Anselum
of Canterbury, another church father. I
was going to say later uh you have a
good question in the chat uh about um
penal substitutionary atonement
essentially and how God's wrath is
poured on the son and how Anselum I
think did a great job of getting into
that
totally. Um so I'm going to read what he
says here. This is from one of Anselam's
uh prayers
and it's called the I'm probably going
to butcher the way that's pronounced
because it's the Latin but the uh proion
um however that's a it's a
faith because of reason or
Yeah. Exactly. And it's a prayer. So
we're going to read this here and I'm
going to show you that this may not have
been the exact site that Roger Olsson
probably not because he probably made
that statement years ago. Faith seeking
reason. There we go.
Oh, right. Right. The Yeah, the the
term. Yeah.
Roger Olsen was clearly reading what
we're going to read here, but not
understanding what he was reading.
So, we're going to read it and then hear
a little bit of commentary from the the
author of this who did understand what
Anselam is saying. So, Anselam said,
"But how are you both merciful and
impassible?
For if you are impassible, you do not
feel compassion. And if you do not feel
compassion, your heart is not sorrowful
out of compassion for sorrow. And that
is what uh and that is what being
merciful is. But if you are not
merciful, how is it that you are such a
comfort to the sorrowful? So he
understands there's a paradox here. If
you don't feel these things, then how
are you these things to us?
So right off the bat, you see he's not
saying that God is not these things.
If you are not merciful, how is it that
you are such a comfort to the sorrowful?
So h so how, Lord, are you both merciful
and not merciful? Is it not because you
are merciful in relation to us, but not
in relation to yourself?
You are indeed merciful according to
what we feel, but not according to what
you feel. We're going to get to this a
little bit more after a bit. For when
you look with favor upon us in our
sorrow, we feel the e the effect of
mercy, but you do not feel the emotion
of mercy. affect him over affectum.
You are merciful because you save the
sorrowful and spare those who sin
against you. But you are also not
merciful because you are not afflicted
with any feeling of compassion for
sorrow.
The author of this article then goes on
to say here Anselam distinguishes
between the effect of the mercy and the
emotion of mercy. While it certainly is
impossible for God to feel any emotion
when he acts mercifully, we feel the
effect of his merciful action. So while
God is merciful according to what we
feel, he's not merciful according to
what he feels since he does not
experience emotion at all. So if you
just take that, you're going to go, "Oh
yeah, see he has no emotions." Keep
reading. The worry for some is that
impassibility, a god who does not change
or feel emotions, seems to be a god who
is impersonal and without love for
creatures or creation. Who does that
sound like? But such a strong reaction,
Anselam would surely say merely is the
result of a confusion on our part. The
reason some might react this way when
considering emotionless divine
impassibility is that they are
anthropomorphizing God. That's what you
said earlier. Making God like we are.
Making God in their image and describing
him in human terms.
Here's where Anselam's emphasis on
eternity before discussing immutability
comes in. We heir in being disturbed by
God is impassible because we are so
accustomed to thinking of worldly things
that are temporal and undergo change. In
thinking about a human being who
experienced no emotions, felt no
compassion for those who suffer or joy
for those he cares about. We are
certainly right in thinking such a
person to be pathological. But there's a
difference in taking this approach to
God and holding this about humans. For
God and humans are not the same kind uh
of of entity. God is an eternal being
and humans are temporal beings. God is
immaterial and humans are embodied. God
is immutable and humans constantly
undergo change and are affected by
external things. That's the key,
including emotions. We are built to be
affected by external things and react to
them. And thus, a human who feels no
emotions is like a knife that won't cut.
But God is not a temporal being. And
since he lacks a body, he can't have the
physiological basis for emotions. Both
Anselum, this is the key folks, both
Anselum and Aquinus have emphasized that
we should be on our toes not to
anthropomorphize God and thus trap
ourselves in the conclusion that God is
impersonal
from the fact that God is immutable.
Anselam offers perhaps the richest
account of this kind of dilemma that I
have ever come across. Anselum is not
saying that God is impersonal and
experiences no no emotions or personal
or or doesn't have any personal relation
to us. That's not what he's saying. What
he is saying is that God is not swayed
by his emotions like we are. I'm going
to read, we've read this before on the
channel, but I'm going to read a
different aspect of it.
This is RC Sproul's exposition of the
Westminster Confession of Faith. This
same phrase without body and parts ex
and and and impassibility is also stated
in our confession along with this
Methodist confession that they were
saying. It is getting at the same point
and saying the same thing that
Augustine, Anselum etc were saying. RC
Sproul explains this very well speaking
about the phrase without passions which
is what he quoted earlier when he said
that they disagreed with one of the
aspects of orthodox trinitarianism which
is that God has no passions and they
took that to mean that God is then not
personal. So let's read it. It's very
it's short sentence here or paragraph
here where RC Sproul explains what this
line means. Let's see if that's what it
is.
So he says, "God is without passions."
Speaking on that line of the confession,
there's often confusion on this subject.
Heresies have resulted from attributing
emotional disturbances and upheavalss to
God.
For example, the tranquility and
felicity that God enjoys in and of
himself is eternal and immutable.
Without passions means that he does not
experience mood swings or become
depressed.
Not that he has no cares.
Yet scripture plainly teaches that Jesus
or or sorry plainly teaches that God was
has an emotive side. He takes delight in
things. He loves. He regards us with
affection. God is not an abstract force
but a personal being. The phrase without
passions means that God is not subject
to human passions. The Bible states that
he is a jealous God. But that but that
does not mean that he is a is jealous of
us. He is jealous for us and for his
holiness. That is, he cares strongly
about it. Even his wrath manifests his
grave concern for the behavior of his
creatures. The pioneers of this movement
had no clue what they were critiquing or
what they were up, what they were
against, what they were vehematly
stating is false and wrong, etc. They
didn't know what they were talking
about. Yet, these are the people that
have handed their belief system down to
Adventists today who are essentially
regurgitating these things whether they
know it or not.
Two things. Um well, I'm so glad you you
quoted from Truths We Confess where RC
is kind of going through the Westminster
um confession, right?
Um beautiful. And I know John Gersonner
on Ligonier um he has an in-depth look
at the Westminster Confession of Faith
as well. um my church, we're actually
going through um another book of RC
Sproul of everyone's a theologian, an
introduction to systematic theology. It
it's phenomenal. Um and so yeah, is to
me I loved how RC was just bringing out
how God doesn't get depressed. We're
saying we're saying God is does not
possess the attributes of emotions one
to one the same way that we do. We're
getting back into the creator creation
distinction. He is his attributes,
right?
Yes.
And so the only other thing I was going
to say is RC Sproul is a Baptist now.
Oh, why? Because he's in eternity.
Yeah, that's right.
Good one.
I've been sitting on that one.
To be determined.
There you go.
There's a TVD next to that.
Yeah.
So, we got the final section here that I
want to look at in this paper and then
folks, we'll we'll take your questions.
I know this is going pretty long, but
this is important. Um, the these things
are are very important and I wanted to
knock this all out in one. This is
probably gonna I'll probably splice this
up and this will end up being uh the
what I used for the Trinity series I was
going to do. Just decided to do it all
tonight with you. Um, and then
surprise that on me.
Yeah. And then get into some some other
things. So, we continue here final part.
So he's still describing the ways that
it radically departs from the medieval
dogma which again we could get into the
medieval dogma the idea of which I get
that Anselum yeah you're talking in the
medieval period but man you've got
people long before Anselum um yeah it's
just it's interesting that they again
equate that's another boogeyman that
they like to to point things on like he
said earlier the immortality of the soul
was a result of you know Greek uh
presuppositions that were picked up and
brought in during the medieval period
and Yet again, you can read
what's what's bogus is
you can read City of God and it's like
uh no this is before the medieval period
and Augustine was often times quoting
other church fathers. But go ahead.
Well, I was just thinking um a lot of
times critics of the New Testament try
to point out how, you know, John is
being too uh Greek minded, you know, the
the prologue. And it's like, look,
everything that we can find in the New
Testament and the categories that we're
talking now, we can easily go into the
Old Testament to show that this
originated in Jewish thought.
Yes. Well, and that's what I was saying
earlier about the Targam. Um I think
it's tar I don't remember if it's tar it
might be both. Tarum Jonathan or Suda
Jonathan and Tarum Neaphiti um on well
there's multiple places and Anthony
Rogers talks about this a lot um he's
going to be on the show by the way folks
next Thursday um to talk about the high
priestly role of Christ and we're going
to bury 1844 in the investigative
judgment so tune in for that um but he
talks about this regularly quoting from
the targets showing that um well he uses
oftentimes intertestamental Judaism and
second temple Judaism to show that um
there was a plurality understanding uh
in line with what we're saying about the
trinity. Um, but he says here again,
he's kind of beating a dead horse here.
She described the unity of the father
and the son, the holy spirit in
relational rather than ontological
terms. While the traditional doctrine
defined the divin the divine unity in
terms of being or substance, she focused
on the vitional and relational
dimensions of their unity, a unity of
purpose, mind, and character. In this
sense, her concept of the heavenly trio
is a more humble concept than the
traditional trinity doctrine. As
Fernando Canal, one of their former
theologians, observes, uh, and I say
former because I think he's passed away,
not because he left the Adventist
church.
As Fernando Canal observes, in no way
could human minds achieve what the
classic doctrine about the Trinity
claims to perceive, namely the
description of the inner structure of
God's being together with the entire
creation. We must accept God's oneness
by faith. Ellen White's emphasis,
however, on the relational unity of God,
get this, does not preclude an onlogical
unity of being in substance as well, but
recognizes that the evidence for the
ontological unity transcends the limits
of our human reason. So, did you notice
what he said earlier that it's their
their view is the more humble view, but
then he he says here, however, there
still is probably an ontological unity.
It's just not as explicit in the
scriptures. Yeah, this to me is playing
like the shell game because this is
where I'm getting back to this is why
having a distinction between being a
person is so necessary because they're
contradicting themselves here as far as
I'm concerned. They're saying the beings
are distinct and yet they're they're
unified. So they're kind of going back
to the critique that the Jehovah's
Witnesses have a lot of times
misinformed at Christianity, but do you
believe in one God or do you believe in
three gods? And so this just modeled how
they're oscillating back and forth with
a logical contradiction.
Yes. And notice this final sentence.
Adventists, pay very close attention
here.
Both Fernando Canal and Fritz Guy
have warned against the danger of
tritheism
if the relational unity is
overemphasized to the exclusion of the
ontological unity.
There it is.
They recognize it. They know it.
They don't want to go down that road,
though, folks, because it's going to
create problems with the writings of
Ellen White.
That will supposedly create problems
with the spirit of prophecy, aka the
Holy Spirit manifesting in the writings
of Ellen G. White and Jesus speaking
there as the testimony of Jesus.
That's why they don't want to go there.
But they rightly recognize and if you
remember in the clip we played from Jed
Lake at the beginning he's transitioning
from someone else who just gave a talk
and they were ending with a Q&A and he
was going up there and he said one thing
on the Q&A
the question about tritheism. Why do you
think people are asking questions about
tritheism?
Why do you think they have to say things
like this? Because this is the problem
that's popping up and then they have to
deal with it. They want to have this
middle ground limbo that like, well,
that's all Greek pagan mythology. But we
understand that, yeah, you do have to
have that if you want to actually be uh
saying that it's one god and not three
gods, but it's still pagan. And you
can't play both sides of the field,
folks. You can't play both sides of the
field. You guys can start sending your
questions through. I know there's a
slight delay with the chat um from us,
but any questions you guys have, we'll
answer a few questions. I know it's
getting late here. Um, but if there are
questions previously, um, I will bring
up some of those.
But it was specifically about, uh, the
father pouring the wrath on the son. I
thought it was a good question for us to
maybe touch on.
Well, if that person uh, hears that and
can send that through again, put a Q in
front of your question, please, so we
can quickly distinguish it from the rest
of the comments. Um,
we got a a question here which it
doesn't have a Q, but Zachariah Rutled
asks, "Can we be so dogmatic?"
Yep. Um, yeah. So, when people ask me,
you know, Jeremiah, what is first tier
doctrine? What are the heels that we die
on? And so, I I kind of give two points,
and I've already alluded to it in our
discussion this evening. You got to
believe in the right Jesus and you have
to receive the right Jesus on the terms
that he prescribed. And so I go back to
John 8:24. Jesus says, "Unless you
believe that ego me um then you will die
in your sins." Well, Jesus is giving us
the bar of who he is ontologically. He's
not created. He's the creator. He's the
eternally I am. And we understand the
eternal creator is tripal. Jesus is the
second person of the creator of Yahweh.
And so you got to believe in that Jesus
in order to have your sin forgiven.
That's number one.
And then number two is the Galatian one
heresy. If you add any works um if you
add anything uh your accomplishments to
the already finished work of Jesus, then
you've totally u corrupted the entire
gospel. you've departed from a gospel of
grace to legalism and estrange yourself
from Christ. And so we're we're dogmatic
on this because uh the trinity is a
non-negotiable. Now some people say,
"Well, do you have to understand the
inner workings and depth of the trinity
to be saved?" No. But you can't deny who
the trinity is. Uh 1 John 2, we have the
the anointing, the the Holy Spirit that
guards us from heresy. And so I don't
think it's possible for someone to be
regenerated to fundamentally deny uh the
triune God. Doesn't mean um this this
kind of goes back to even my testimony.
I I believe I was trusting in the
biblical Jesus, but uh the church that I
grew up in was teaching me a form of
modalism that that God is kind of like a
father who is also a son and a brother,
but I was affirming the trinity. So
there are merciful inconsistencies, but
we dogmatically teach the trinity. Um,
and we dogmatically teach salvation by
faith apart from works.
Yeah, that's good. And even outside of
like the mechanics of being a person,
you still have issues in Adventism. We
read those quotes earlier. Jesus was
exalted to be made equal with the father
was given omnipresence while he was on
earth. He veiled and gave up his
divinity. They affirm the kotic heresy
such that he was only a man while he was
on earth who could have sinned. They
don't believe in the uh well the
inability to to sin. Um and so he
doubted his resurrection on the cross.
He doubted whe or he yeah he doubted if
he'd be resurrected on the cross because
the devil was able to twist his heart
causing him to doubt and he didn't know
if he'd be eternally separated from the
father.
He remained all that he was remained in
his body that laid in the tomb. Ellen
White made it clear that Christ was not
conscious during that period and that
only the father could resurrect him. You
start getting into these sorts of
details, this is not compatible with
trinitarianism. So, no, of course, every
person's not going to understand and be
able to fully wrap their head around the
the every bit of the mechanics and
stuff. That's why I was saying at the
beginning of the stream, the language
that we use is so important because it's
describing something specific. We don't
we're not Jeremiah and I are not
claiming that we understand the
mechanics of all of this. That's
different than claiming here's what the
Bible portrays though and that's what I
believe by faith.
It's like saying God spoke the world
from nothing. Excellent nihilo. I can
affirm that. How did he do it? I can't
tell you how God did that
or how God is all knowing. How is God
all knowing? How is God uh omnipresent?
I don't know. I just know that that's
what the Bible teaches. How is God
eternal? Well, you're asking me, a
creature in time, to explain something
that transcends time. I can't do it.
Well, we didn't look at it in here, but
he also talks about in this article, one
of the things that uh they reject as
well is the timelessness of God. They
think that's a Greek pagan mythology um
and presupposition
33.
Yeah, they uh so that's another reason
why you have this physical corporeal
because God is a part of of time. So,
Zechariah, thanks for the question
there. We got a fun question here.
Anthony Rogers is in the house. He says,
"Who is that bearded fellow?" Um, well,
Anony's also a bearded fellow, so I feel
a little bit left out here.
You got a little mustache going on
there. I like it.
Yeah. Got to go from one bearded fellow
to another. Anthony, thanks for being
here.
Um, got a question. I found Okay, so
after this, Derek is the one that asked
the question earlier I want to touch on.
So, just remind me and we'll touch on
cool. So, he asks, "I'm still in this
mess, but working my way out. Thank you
both. How do you explain God forsaking
himself or abandoning himself? Because
God can't abandon himself being one
being. Appreciate it.
That's the same question he asked
earlier.
Okay, you tackle it if you've got
anything and then I'll have something to
say,
bro. I got something. I don't know if
it's good, but I got something.
Okay, go for it.
Well, so we we know the phrase where
Jesus on the cross said, "My God, my
God, why have you forsaken me?" He's
quoting Psalm 22 and that psalm is
exhaust. Jesus is quote that's the thing
and when Dr. pointed this out. I was
like, "Oh, thank you. I've always known
that Jesus is not announcing a departure
ontologically him from the father." But
Jesus is simply hearkening back to the
hearers. Psalm 22, go look at Psalm 22
because that is being fulfilled before
your very eyes. And so, uh, when he
says, "My God, why my God, why have you
forsaken me?" You got to think about,
uh, the trinity. There's not a radical
departure but from eternity past there
has been perfect harmon harmony loving
relationship between father son and
spirit and so Jesus is the sinbearer um
Isaiah 53 like he he is bearing our sin
guilt and so when we start talking about
you know wrath as a divine attribute
it's interesting because you start
talking about well where is wrath in
eternity past well I think one of the
best ways to to explain The attribute of
wrath is divine love, justice, holiness.
When it meets sin, when it meets evil,
wickedness, well, then we we see we see
kind of the backside of divine love.
It's wrath, right? That is a loving,
just, and holy thing for God to meet sin
with wrath, with a justice. And so what
you do see between father and son is the
wrath of the father for the first time
to be poured out on the son. That does
not mean a radical departure
ontologically between father and son. It
just is articulating Isaiah 53 1 Peter
3. I mean literally the gospel account
of what it looks like for the father to
pour out his wrath. for Jesus who knew
no sin to become sin on our behalf that
we might become the righteousness of
God. What do you think?
That's good. Um you you covered a lot of
things there. I think also too it kind
of gets back to what we were saying
about terms. Um because when we say
himself being one being,
right?
We have to get into this the specifics
here because when we ask who is God,
God is father, son, and holy spirit.
So
he's one what and three who's.
Yes. And so this is why we use these
terms person and being because it's not
God. This this question is almost the
presupposition behind the question and
Derek I'm not faulting you by this for
way by the way. I'm just pointing this
out. Um the presupposition behind this
is almost like a modalist
thinking of like well the one person
it's almost like there's one person like
how can the one person abandon himself?
So you rightfully pointed out that Jesus
is actually quoting from the Psalms
there for a specific reason. This was a
common thing that he did to quote the
scriptures in the moment while it's
happening. Um but also even just in
examining the the question itself, it's
kind of the wrong question because it's
not that God uh was abandoning himself
because there is a plurality in the
category of himself. That's the category
of of personhood. So
I think I think Anthony would be proud
of us with that answer.
Totally. I've learned a lot on this
specific doctrine from uh from him.
though. Kevin asks, "Where did Ellen
White get her tritheism from?" Um, I say
from yeah, the from demonic uh
influence. I don't doubt that Ellen
White had legitimate visions in the
sense that she actually experienced some
things. There were lots of people around
that region of the country at that time
who were experiencing all sorts of
fanaticism and craziness. Ellen White
came from the shouting Methodist. That's
what she was raised in as a kid. She was
sunk into and permeated into this
hypercarismania from a very early age in
a time period where this was having all
sorts of upheaval and ramifications in
all sorts of groups and movements. So I
don't doubt that the woman had visions
but when you test those things up
against the scriptures they fail. Um
which means that they were and even in
her own words um she says if her words
contradict scripture they have to be
from Satan. Um so that is the case over
and over and over again. So, I'm going
to say from the devil because anything
that's not from God in this regard is
pro uh positing an idol, a false god
that's not from God.
Would she be really mad at that? Because
doesn't Satan like totally help with the
the what is it from Psalm 16? Isn't he
the scapegoat? So, he's he's a big part
in the plan of redemption. So, would she
be mad at us for saying, you know, she's
hearing stuff from
Well, and again, you get into the terms
of like redemption and what they mean by
that because if you've seen my streams
dedicated to the great controversy
theme, um I've got one going up with
your friends actually. Um Dr. Josh
Howard, I was on his podcast. He's
actually a pastor in uh Battle Creek,
Michigan, where Ellen White is buried.
um a huge huge area for Seventh Day
Adventist, Barryian Springs as well. Um
but yeah, I uh was on his podcast and we
were talking about um a number of these
things. So, I'll save the rest of that
for then. Heck
yeah, I'm looking forward to that
episode.
Totally. It goes up uh in a couple weeks
um or like week and a half or so. Folks,
that is all of the questions. I know we
went super long tonight. Um brother,
thank you so much for being on here. um
let people know your YouTube channel is
linked in I believe both the title and
the description box of the video so
people can check your channel out that
way. Anywhere else you want to point
people to and then I'll do a final sign
off and get us closed out for the night.
Yes. Uh YouTube channel, The Apologetic
Dog. Uh I'm over a thousand subscribers,
Miles, which is which is awesome. So I'm
learning some of those new features. Um
definitely want to point people to my
Facebook page. I'm kind of old. I'm
turning 31 in a couple weeks. So,
Facebook is kind of the extent. I'm
eventually gonna get into Instagram
world and things like that later, but
I'm still on Facebook. Um, definitely
email me. You can find my email on my
Facebook or my YouTube channel. And then
I also want to tell people I serve as
pastor and elder um with Pastor Nathan
at 125 Church in Jonesboro, Arkansas.
So, if you're in northeast Arkansas,
anywhere close, we'd love for you to
come and visit 125, be a part of our
fellowship, be a part of our service.
Uh, we do things a little bit different.
Um, uh, we we have a pretty intensive,
um, extensive liturgy. Uh, but the
service does not end after the preaching
of the sermon and taking of communion.
Uh, we go into Coinia feast, Miles,
where we have a ton of food. It's
wonderful time to get to know guests,
get to know uh spend time with uh the
people here at 125. And then we have
sermon Q&A uh sermon discussion which
almost everyone stays for and then we
have our benediction at the end of that
because we want to encourage people to
partake in all that.
Do you do the baby baptisms after the
benediction?
You know, our closest thing to baby
baptism is probably baby dedication.
I figured you'd like that, but
yeah. Um, oh, expository preaching to me
and that's where I love my Presbyterian
brothers, uh, because we understand
verse by verse exposition is how we draw
out truth from God's word rather than
imposing our thoughts and ideas onto the
text.
Amen. Well, brother, thank you for being
on here as always. Um, I'm sure we'll do
another one of these sometime in the
future. Um, always a pleasure.
See you, Miles. Thanks again for having
me on.
Absolutely.
All right, folks. So,
there you have it. Um, I hope that was
beneficial. I know that was a lot. If
you need to come back, rewatch this,
that's why this is here. Um, hopefully
this will be a blessing to many people.
Um, we're not just doing these things to
harp on Adventists. I've been getting an
exceptional number of you guys who have
been commenting who continue to say, so
I'm going to continue to also say if I
was simply doing this to rag on Seventh
Adventists because I have nothing better
to do.
I it just it's just not the case, folks.
So you guys can keep saying that to make
yourself feel better. That's not why we
do this. We do this because this stuff
needs to be said. This is serious. Your
own scholars recognize these issues that
are posited. I talk with hundreds of
Seventh Day Adventists every month. This
is one of the foundational fundamental
things I'm always jumping to. They want
to talk about the Sabbath and Jesus
being the Lord of the Sabbath and the
law of God. I say, "Whoa, hold up.
Before we can even get to that, step one
is who is Jesus? Who is God? Explain who
God is to me. Who is God?" Then we start
peeling back the layers and they don't
even know. They're talking about some
other god. You guys want to talk about
Presbyterian churches, Protestant
churches, Roman Catholic churches being
Babylon because they're doctrally
confused. Folks, no one in my church is
an Aryan heretic.
No one in Jeremiah's church is an Aryan
heretic.
We are all united on the foundational
fundamentals. You're not going to find
any division in our churches along those
lines
unless it's some secret thing that some
person's just not saying.
We are united around the fundamentals.
So, it's laughable to make the claim
that this organization does that we're
Babylon because we're doctrinally
confused when I talk with hundreds of
Adventists and hear about all sorts of
different gods. People that are, "Yeah,
Jesus isn't God. Only the Father's God.
Yeah, we believe in the Trinity." Then
you start asking them, "Oh, it's the
heavenly trio." Well, only the the
father and the the spirit or only the
father and the son are god because the
holy spirit's not actually personal.
You've got all the different time frames
of this movement's evolution on this
position. And you'll find people that
affirms the the positions from the
various points.
This is foundational. You can't talk
about the law of God and the Sabbath,
which is supposed to be a commemoration
of the creator when you don't even have
the right creator.
It's crazy to me. It's absolutely crazy
to me. You can be an ancient Aryan
heretic in this movement, but you can't
eat bacon.
You're you're called to be a vegetarian.
That's going to be the deli aisle. We're
going to cut the line. But not if you
have a different god. Adventists, wake
up. Wake up, folks. The alarm clock is
sounding. It's time to wake up. It's
time to get serious about this.
leave this movement that is leading you
after a false god of people who are
confused on the most fundamental aspects
of the Christian faith. We will accept
and embrace you with open arms. We don't
hate you. We don't hate the law of God.
We don't hate the Sabbath. All these
sort of tropes and stereotypes that at a
certain point you just water under the
bridge.
Leave this movement. Come to know the
truth. The church has not been lost. The
church did not get confused
in terms of who God is such that the
church has been worshiping a false god
for 1,800 years until a bunch of Aryan
ancient heretics rose up from a movement
called the Christian connection that
joined Millerism that then supposedly is
restoring the church.
Yet then they evolved over time
regarding who God is.
No, God was not behind that folks.
It's not the remnant church.
Like I mentioned, next week, Anthony
Rogers is going to be on the channel.
We're going to be talking about the high
priestly role of Christ, what that looks
like. We're going to be talking about
1844. I'm actually going to be playing
devil's advocate during this discussion.
Um, and I'm going to let him, he's a
theological beast, um, answer these
these questions so you can see that the
Adventist church is very wrong on this.
And this is the central pillar of the
Adventist church. All roads lead back to
1844, even the great controversy. So
he'll be on the show next Thursday. Next
Monday before that, Arthur and Theresa
Beam are going to be on here. Former
Adventists. They're now Roman Catholic.
I'm not Roman Catholic, obviously, but
um we don't only have conversations with
people that we agree with on every jaw
and tit. It's okay to have conversations
with people who don't see things the way
that you do. I've talked with them
offline. great people doing great
things. Um, obviously we have
disagreements, but we're gonna have a
great discussion about their journey out
of Seventh Day Adventism. They wrote a
book. It's called It's Okay to Not Be a
Seventh Day Adventist. So, we're going
to talk about that a little bit as well.
The following week, I have a challenge
out. We'll see if the gentleman wants to
respond um for him to come on. He wants
to prove to us that um the Adventist
position of the mark of the beast is
completely scriptural, can be supported.
It's just clearcut, clear as day. Um, so
if you're listening to this stream, sir,
which I know that you probably are.
Let's see it. Let's see it. You've been
bothering me for months. You're now
getting your 15 minutes of of attention.
Let's see it. Show up and show everyone.
We're going to give him five to 15
minutes to give his best presentation
and sell us on this position.
And then um we're going to have a
discussion after that and see if this is
as clear as the Adventist church wants
us to believe. So with that said, thanks
again for being here. Um I'm going to
start ending the shows now with the
thing that I heard and still hear
oftentimes from Adventists and I'm going
to say it back to you all. Come out of
her, my people.
[Music]